so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
good afternoon
what's going on realm talk to me what is
going on outside
it is sunday it is the lord's day we are
back
explosive discussions
lots to talk about you already know what
it is gerald mack i see you bright and
early
salute let me know how my levels are
sounding how we doing out here iop in
the building salute canada's best 100
what's up
i don't think we're going to see him
carol kennedy's best
are you babe what's going on man how are
you good good weekend for morocco all
right morocco in the building salute
okay xbox about okay joe mack with the
little man i see you know what i'm
saying the board game renegade salute
marine 69.99 what's going on
all right y'all you're here early ain't
it early down to taco what's up i see
what's going on loon 87 times what's up
barry burton what's going on here for
jeffrey you already know we're trying to
get the legend in the building should be
coming through soon
and uh yeah akw what's up awful grim
bones what's going on crazy horse what's
up
[Music]
what's going on uk bahamas okay
everybody thought up they said aurora
wolf
where is your boo aurora wolf
i'm looking for him
oh
you're welcome sorry i'm sorry juan
andres
fiolini diaz all right venezuela in a
building salute hustling the building
what's up
yeah rdj super hyped for the show that's
what i'm talking about william blank
ship let's go playstation rewind let's
go
all right the the
okay we got a lot of people already up
in here early
should be a fun one i spoke to the kid
king will be pulling up you know what
i'm saying no doubt hustle i see you i
see
and uh yes i will be in the building so
it should be good too you know he had a
lot going on so it should be a full lord
card wait no addict you should be in the
building too and then yeah we got the
legendary david jaffee so i'm gonna go
pull up on him right quick make sure we
get him into the realm nice and smooth
put him in front of the congregation we
gotta make sure he we're gonna see how
this language thing go
he said he was gonna hold me down but we
gonna see i go you know you know he's
passionate but uh we got a lot to talk
about y'all i'm all very excited el
domingo what's up hi max what up phoenix
dan what up
and um yeah everybody get cozy in the
front of the congregation this is gonna
be a nice one and i'm looking forward to
it so i'll see y'all in a bit salute
corey mosley
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
about coastal
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with the gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't heard a boy or you ain't gotta say
it i'm embarrassed for you i've always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you're just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you were messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social my city
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all haven't messed up and turned
me to an animal and headless be swearing
they real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
keeping these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
i'm better than money because you can
bank on me being accountable i know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
[Music]
you could say that i'm very spoiled for
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell an uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
[Music]
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beating they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on aim
[Music]
very spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you i
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
and we are live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line this is that
standard this is what we use right now
kind of our caffeine substitute and what
we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on debt number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advanced gg.com use code iron lord on
the checkout this is something i use all
the time got to support advanced gg
great products if you want to get your
workout on even if you don't work out
you're just gaming you need that focus
and again the hydration line for those
who don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lower
cognito here iron law podcast
peace
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though i know
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really watch that you can't never
still be the king of the statues since
the juvenile i've been cursed with a
curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable because you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's
day if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right hi mike hi mike and we will
actually do a little mic check right
quick so we'll make sure the levels yeah
i see levels i like that i like levels
hear ye hear ye and we are live welcome
to the iron lord podcast llc and also
live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 257
it's another glorious sunday we're back
at the round table on the lord's date
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got star field and red
fall delays
god of war ragnarok and sony financials
and sony strategy versus game pass to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only an iconic director within our games
industry but whose tremendous influence
shaped an identity on sony platforms and
his candid opinions reverberate on any
podcast
introducing the game director of the
legendary god of war franchise
co-director co-creator of the twisted
metal series and the host of the gabbing
and games podcast
the lord of kratos sweet tooth and phil
collins
who always reminds doordash the
principalities of proper food delivery
love from california by way of alabama
and kind enough to make his debut into
the realm of the lords
my man lord david jaffe how we doing sir
i am doing very good that's very nice
kind introduction i appreciate it um
lately i've been on some podcasts that
have been a little uh
you know rough and so this is like
coming to a this is like a spa
so i i appreciate the kind words uh i'm
doing good it's it's kind of early for
me my sleep schedule has been absolutely
wrecked since the pandemic
i haven't gotten any better i haven't
gotten over it and so i'm going to bed
at three four o'clock
but i'm happy to be here i like y'all's
show i appreciate you having me and uh
yeah i'm i'm feeling good feeling good
appreciate your view i'd usually be in
church you know oh yeah oh no no oh yeah
look man i appreciate you uh
dealing with the time difference and uh
making taking the time about your day
but look man you are lord at what you do
one of the icons in the game so we go
have some fun but other than that like
what you've been playing man
a lot um
i
have been playing let's see i
i'm still playing elden ring um i'm
about 160 hours in and people are like
you're not finished with that yet and
i'm like you know
i'm doing a lot of leveling up and
grinding because i i don't have the
skill set to like just figure out the
boss patterns everywhere there's so many
bosses
so i'm playing that
i played a wonderful game the other day
called nightmares of decay uh on steam
which is a like a ps1 first person
version of resident evil but then it
takes its own
path that's really great yeah
uh i'm playing uh
at what's called evil dead we played the
other night which was awesome i saw a
little bit of the stream so a little bit
yeah
really fun uh
i'm playing uh hearthstone again i
stayed away from all the activision
stuff and then i realized that bobby
codex on the way out so i felt like
that was good
the ward is nice the world is nice there
that's right and so i'm i'm back to
being addicted to hearthstone i'm
playing rogue legacy 2.
i'm playing wwe 2k 22. i mean i'm i'm
playing a cred ton look at me say crud
time yo yeah i see what you're doing
put the symbol up on the lord
i appreciate you you can change
let the spirit move you brother come to
the front of the congregation
oh man
anyway absolute pleasure we got a lot of
show and you already know we got the
four horsemen of gaming those original
lords of the rub here at the round table
with time sensitive intros because we
have to maximize king's time anyway my
co-host with the co-host we're a brother
from bandana the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord addict
of the attic show how we doing sir i'm
doing pretty good man uh one thing i
will say is
i'm playing the game uh i'm reviewing it
right now and i will say when you guys
see this game in a couple days like
but i've played dark souls type games i
have but this
these bosses in this game man
so that the guy gonna be lit that's what
that said
no
my my anger's lit like
it's like you're frustrated i'm not
playing the game yeah like i was sitting
there playing i fought like there's this
boss where you fight like this giant
insect and they keep like low like
shortening
the the map over and over again so after
they did it once i'm like all right this
is what it is i like this this is like a
one-on-one thing and then they did it
again and i'm like okay no i don't want
to be that close to her well let's back
it up a little bit
it's it's a rough game man but uh it's
definitely gonna be a good show uh uh
appreciate uh jeffrey for coming on here
and uh you know we're gonna get stuff
and i'm gonna i'm gonna shut up so keen
can take the rest of my time yes thank
you
[Laughter]
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives
with a single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patriarch of the iron
bank my man lord sovereign come in hot
today what's up bro
very hot uh
sovereign almost had a funky haircut
this morning because
he's cutting his hair and his clippers
conked out
oh you would have had to have the fade
with the half ball oh my goodness
the backups and the backups you know
aren't as powerful
they're wireless and but you know they
they they came through man
with the back of your head first you
always make sure the front is dead
it's the money maker
don't touch your own hair don't you look
at that
i know i do i started as well i finally
went bald enough up top yeah i was just
like oh it's the best thing ever yes you
gotta let it go like we gotta let the
ego go
see what i haven't did is i haven't uh
financially been as secure as you to let
my you know my grades do what they do
you know everybody sit there and say you
still using that just for me and i'm
like yeah hell yeah
right now you know
i gotta have that little a little ten
years younger look okay we're taking it
back
though you
yeah
it's coming it's it's it's creeping up
and i'm trying how old are you right now
oh no see i'm trying to we're not gonna
do that
you're getting close dude
look jeffy you get close
he's approaching no but
listen what i'm gonna do is i'm i'm
gonna delay it i'm i'm gonna put in like
a six month or eight month delay okay
our build ain't ready
there you
okay then what you should do is you
should let phil spencer manage your age
and you'll never reach 50. here we go
okay so we're not going to be attacking
dominance
i love phil spencer i really don't
i know you do because i saw the tweet
and people uh miscaptioned you of course
yeah i know she did it
you know why i never you know why i
never tweet about um
the ceo of ubisoft because i don't give
a [ __ ] about him language he lost it
you know listen
don't worry hopefully that'll change too
yeah that's so good
we will we will discuss that all right
very little in the way of gaming and
still playing uh mlb the show and i felt
like for whatever reason i felt like
playing a link to the past so i've been
playing that
no doubt and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the excess
gamer
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement be
loving lord king how we doing sir doing
fantastic i want to thank everybody that
came out last night to watch me combat
talk with the king yes it was incredible
you guys keep making it possible for me
to actually live that dream of uh
broadcasting
and talking about fights with people and
engaging with others so i have other
things coming it will be other overlays
call-ins uh different ways to interact
what you got i want to have it the most
interactive boxing show that you're ever
going to see so it's it's a lot of fun
stuff coming we fixed the mic from last
week shout out to attic for doing such a
wonderful job with me right before the
show yes he is like my little technical
engineer because me personally i'm
technologically stunted to be honest
with that you get right you're good but
he works with me jamelle charlo won the
super uh walter weight
uh championship as far as
all four belts he's a unified undisputed
champion and that division has never
been one so shout out to him and shout
out to castano for taking those punches
all the way through those guys gave a
hell of a fight shout out to get beat up
here no but he was giving as much as he
got it's just you know when you're
fighting so hard and you get hit he got
hit with a left hook that was in close
it was so beautiful
in his in his brutality that his body
just crumbled his mind wanted to be
there and he looked like no god not now
it's over
i want to say
i only have four people on my bucket
list that i want to interview let's go
right four four people i advocated for
david jackson's yeah so much lord jaffe
this was yeah
they were like oh but you know as a
language i said well you know what
listen i i'm gonna have to do uh lords
after dark i'm gonna have to do it
because i saw you i saw you doing
youtube i said he's outside oh god i i
actually have a chance
right so it's four people no doubt that
i i
that helped my gaming
life my like
pillars because you know it's four
pillars and
literally
you are a rock star in my eyes at
certain parts because i heard an
interview that you did
and that interview
um really irritated the hell out of me
because i said
you have somebody that has accomplished
something that you honestly
and he will be remembered like you know
that movie troy when he walks in
your name it's it's it's a guy out there
he's so big
i would never fight him he said no one
will ever remember your name you did to
be great when the time needed it and
your name will reverberate for forever
so it's it's things that you did that
formula i don't know who you're talking
about i'm talking i'm talking about you
sir no no no no i mean in in trouble
like oh when it uh
okay well that's nice that's nice that's
i it really is nice it really is kind i
i i'm not like ah shucks or anything
like that i'm just like
i i
i i can't stress enough how much of a
team effort it is
i love my contributions i am proud of
them to those games i
i don't walk around with any kind of ego
like i did this i don't know
i'm on to the next thing you know for us
to do okay but but what i will tell you
is i i feel that way about
other people obviously and so all i can
do is hear it and go i don't i can't
relate to it what you're saying about me
because i'm just me
but if that's how you feel that's
staggering to me but i'm happy to be
here and and thank you guys let me
finish giving you your rosa because my
day is gonna be short right
i wanted to ask you about crete was it
called creator clash the boxing thing
yesterday i thought you were going to
talk because i i know that's you know
what i'm talking about you're talking
about what the boxing manager thing that
i did no the influencer i didn't know
you were into boxing yesterday there was
like 20 influencers like from youtube
that went to orlando
and fought
oh boxing rings they got busy oh i wish
i would it was it was yeah i was like
[ __ ] shots i didn't uh i didn't know you
know i was like oh my god you should
have been there yeah put me in put me in
put me in
what they don't want to do with you
it was it was amazing because it was
just these these guys who clearly had no
training at boxing i would have fun and
and it was just like to watch some of
them though really discover holy cow i
have endurance i can hit and then the
guy on the other end receiving it
was like you were saying the guy is like
my heart wants it
i've never been full punched in the face
before yeah
sorry i know you got your time but that
yeah okay no no
it's that's why i love you see and i got
a chance to watch so i i beg for this
interview and these two wonderful
shout outs went out and we're with fawns
shout out to jay fonzarelli shout out to
the games talk live sponsors shout out
the fight do it definitely do us alley
you while you were on this show and yeah
we wanted to facilitate it so salute to
everybody involved you had an interview
and all i can say is i was frustrated at
the fact that you had the apparent you
had the opportunity to have questions
and conversations with an individual and
for whatever reason you felt that it was
time to do uh
this this this stick yeah the disrespect
and not get to
any real questions any real conversation
because at the end of the day it's
plastic but
i i i beg for this part and they really
got it so i got questions later you know
going about your history and an open
book whatever you want to know me oh
we're going to get there no that's why i
want you here
thank you so much i'm sorry i went long
i know because you're talking about to
get your balls off for most of them but
if you got to leave a big show but of
course we got the gaming ninja himself
the shinobi lord cognito spread that
around the iop not telling what you want
to hear but what you need to hear shout
out to defining dude shout out to mr
maddie plays shout out to cole eastwood
pulled up definitely had a good episode
it should be up on youtube now last day
of media and we had that stitching about
the starfield and red fall delay get the
raw reaction check that up also if you
want that uh picture on exclusive we got
that uh drm xbox everywhere situation so
me and maddie kind of break that down in
an offline future shout out to the last
word shout out to bontes thai guy travis
talking destiny pvp my man shadow talk
about the iron banner changes as far as
being with gaming i've been uh slowly
i've been a lot of gaming but track to
you me y'all like
it's like a little artistic little
masterpiece man it's it's simple in
combat it's not doing anything crazy but
even
yeah like it's the dialogue it's the
background to foreground it's the
atmosphere it really puts me in a place
i've been enjoying it you know i'm only
like maybe stage three three stages in
because i've been doing like one stage a
day i don't have much time these days
but um i've been up late until i got to
the end
i fought a boss yes
i've been getting my parry down so soft
will be probably getting my parry down
you know what i'm saying doing that
nobody leaving that nonsense
you know what if you play song and
you'll be rolling i know every game you
play you roll you gotta parry but
the counter you know what i mean the
it's the gameplay bro you didn't you
didn't parry in in second row yeah
second did you probably attic you have
to pay oh he said he did be grudgingly
you're right
you can't just dodge away if you try to
do that yeah you're gonna die little
doubt so we're doing that and then vr
actually y'all played this game um
remember it's called little cities
remember when sim city first came out
king like when it first came out we
didn't know what it was you had your
little map you put down your own
residence yeah you're doing a little
residential converting like all right
now people need a place to shop now
people need a place to get a job and
you're making your little city and it's
one of the most relaxing
stress relief games the music is great
it's a small little team i forget the
name i want to shout i shouted about on
twitter check that out if you got a vr
it's really cool it's called little
cities and then i'm still solving prop
store on my mlb to show the methane
eliminated yet so i'm feeling good about
the medicine doing my march to october
yeah
i finished though
i finally finished that game it was
fantastic i'm on the game plus two on
elder ring right now no doubt so let's
get a couple of super chats now and then
we
tell them the rules of engagement with
laura jaffe yeah so how long we have
david we got he rocking he's rocking her
oh
the other david's leaving
[Laughter]
donald taco 10 super chat with breath of
the wild 2 and starfield missing this
year just solidified that the big early
contender would win game of the year by
default kirby is set to completely sweep
the game awards exactly
you ready he ready
ah and my good friend let me play with
your joystick
wow
[Laughter]
continue
what an amazing guest
between the news and the honored guests
hopefully we are forgiven for a few uh
slip ups yes good job traffic good job
good
we got the homie heart geek cheney
salute to the lords and welcome to the
realm lord jaffee jaffe and king on the
bethesda delay is going to be fun
welcome back to lord prophet saab thank
you sir absolutely
then we got hearty city once again two
dollars we chat jaffee already dropping
the f-bombs
he's doing good he's doing good
it's a process that's right
right
addicted to
then we got eric franklin ten dollars of
a chat i can't believe the timing of
today's guest maybe this is the real
reason bethesda delayed two games in one
day only only so they could get to this
moment here very excited for this show
wow you definitely feel like we got the
right guess with these cities now i'm
starting to go what do you i i don't
know your opinion on this so i'm excited
this is like uh you know
we have the night beard remember for
four months thank you sir so happy to
see my favorite content creators united
today have a wonderful day you as well
such love love
you got 600 plus in the chat yeah that
like button every time you hit the like
button you save you save a little child
you
know
we got two more and then we'll move on
then after that guys uh yeah we're gonna
save more of the two super chats for
later on so we'll get into the topics of
the show uh dave is gonna be with us the
whole time so that's fantastic but we'll
kind of spread them out you know i'll
i'll i'll rely on cog to sort of let me
know when it's time to jump in
absolutely um we got chocolate mongoose
remember for four months thank you sir
these dudes
absolutely what happened dude i just
like our latin contingent is up with so
i just like oh yeah
everybody's speaking spanish like click
on my google is outside like i like the
spanish twitter
you see
i like this it's good for the
demographics
have a great episode fellas thank you
sir my god then we got jay barry oh
that's my guy 20 super chat shout out to
my man jaffy with his dlc ass
he ain't like that oh yeah he didn't
like that
yeah i love the fact that he said that
so yeah i could actually understand i
was right
that's how they're gonna be messy
continue i'm just upset that he gets to
say ass and you said hell
no no hell as hell is a place but it's
not it's not a curse
okay so hell and ass are okay oh man no
no no ass ain't okay we gonna stop there
[Laughter]
see that was him he wanted to read that
super chat in his entirety i would have
read it i understood okay so money
trumps morals with you guys oh somebody
pays
no no no that's him that's all we blame
songs
jimmy swagger right here
now i'm starting to understand why you
want this podcast to be available for
kids to watch if this really is like
church
basically right yeah but it's the rest
of mario let me let me finish barry hey
king david sorry about red falling start
from delay but who did that oh my god i
gotta hit him with the emoji i love you
all great the wildest thing is they
should have did that to forbidden west
and gran turismo 7. wow
so those games could actually be
finished but right now
don't do that
shout out to you for playing playstation
4 stuff better then we have spartan go
17 five pound super chat release the
xbox fraud king about to pr the hell out
of this barren wasteland of game driving
oh my god yo i know he was in my dms the
other day right and i told him i said
just watch the show because he wants me
to spin it
i don't have to spend anything i'm
playing stuff you're upset there's
nothing for you
good to you there we have a hollywood
rules five dollar super chat salute the
king on the fight last night awesome
time
another great iop
sunday with the four horsemen hello the
hashtag for the children
i definitely pulled up because i knew my
name wouldn't get butchered
i feel like that's
good afternoon brothers i would be messy
but we have royalty today just kidding
xbox has no games have a great show here
we go so soft set the engagement rules
yes sir so yeah um any super chat coming
from here on out we'll get a little bit
later again uh jaffy's staying with us
the whole time so that's fantastic so we
will get in more super chats before the
end of the show but i'll just i'll count
on on on college to kind of let me know
it's a good time to jump in with them no
doubt no doubt so now that we've gotten
into what the lords have been playing
and all that good stuff we got to focus
on lord david jaffe his video game
system history his journey into the
games industry with sony being the lead
director of the legendary god of war
franchise co-creative twisted metal and
of course what sparked his passion into
content creation and the gavin and games
podcast so hello jeffrey let's start
from the very beginning what was some of
the first video game systems you had and
what got oh man into gaming let's go
well
the very first game i played uh
was a game called boot hill which was an
arcade game and it was so basic
that it was a uh i remember we were on
vacation in florida and it was uh the
background was hand art and it was just
a
glass screen
that the
uh i guess it was just the pixels were
projected on
and so it was just two gun fighters
shooting each other right uh super
simple but i was in love immediately and
then my dad brought home something
called
i want to say it was called a telestar
but it was
it was before atari 2600 by like maybe a
year
and it was really neat it was this
triangular
console okay and on one side of the
triangle it had a steering wheel and on
this other side of the triangle it had a
place for the gun
and then the other side it had like pong
things and whenever you're talking about
yeah and they would sell cartridges that
look like little triforce little
triangles
yeah and you put those in and every
cartridge used all three sides depending
on what game you were playing
and my dad brought that home and
you know i he just you know we were kids
so he's just like i guess kids will like
this and we felt we fell in love with it
and then from there it just never ended
i mean it was like i was an arcade kid
and i was an atari kid a coleco vision
kid
um my buddy had in television so i loved
going over there that's one of the
reasons the console wars is always weird
to me because
one of my best friends even to this day
carrie had in television and i had the
atari and we were just like come over
and play dungeons and dragons
he came over to my place and played indy
500 and yeah you know it was just on and
on and on and so uh
and then the the core industry crashed
in 84.
but ethi
uh yeah yeah
i mean
atari getting bought by warner brothers
and everybody just
channeling in
junk for the most part
and um
but i i was learning to program i'm not
i'm not like some kind of oh i'm you
know it was basic like literally the
basic language but i loved it we had an
apple 2e we had a trs 80. so we were
we had tons to play even during the
crash um wait so you were learning the
program then
yeah i took um
but i'm not like machine language or
anything like that you know
yeah it was like 10 clear screen 20
right yeah hello you know and i was
making my little stupid games and stuff
that were like adventure games and stuff
and i loved it and and i was uh how old
was you i was
uh
probably like
10 to 11. yeah that is it bro wait hold
your kick is right okay stop that we're
going to just gloss over my little games
like okay so you 10 and 11 and you're
back then when it's you know you got to
pull up prompts and stuff and you got to
actually put in manual all right
what what what made you
think to do that like i'm just trying to
get to your thought process because i
don't
remember
why
my parents signed me and my brother and
our friends up for this
well we got signed up for a computer
class obviously we wanted to go it was
every saturday and it sounds creepy but
it was down in this basement of these
people's homes
but you would but you would go down in
their basement alabama
i had to add it i had to add
that
we had the sweet tea you came in you got
the sweet tea and then you went through
sort of how to be a racist going down
this building
and if you pass that test then you could
get into the computer room
yeah so so it was uh but yeah you would
go down there and there were probably
about 25 computers which
oh what you know and there were like the
trs-80s and the apples and whatnot
and
the the thing that really left
impression is i remember walking past
the shelf where they had all their video
games right and it was the first time i
had ever seen
games that were sort of presented like a
library and it was like the boxes back
then were really big and nice designs on
this on the spines and so it was just
like you know so that really was
impressive that it's like wow you guys
at any time of the day could just go up
and take
wizardry off the shelf or jagged
alliance or some adventure
and
that's you know so that really got got
me and so
um but yeah i was you know but again
let's be clear i mean i i i understand
there is a way you could paint someone
who's like wow you were 10 and
programming a computer i mean
it basic is
you know kids are really good with
computers kids are good with that kind
of logic if you get them early enough
and i still could program in basic today
i remember a lot of it yeah
but i the minute i started to try to get
to pascal and other languages i was like
yeah that's no you know that's not my
cup of tea so uh but yeah i was doing
that and and and then suddenly after
even though i had a lot to play
and i remember there was one christmas
where
i wanted to play like a console again
and there were none to be found
the only thing that was out
was uh a
a game that they that had a
full motion video on the tv yeah you had
like a cursor that you could follow
around like you were a jet fighter and
top gun or something and that was it
yeah and the next time i went into the
toy store which was about five or six
months later suddenly there was the nes
and
and after that it was like it's never
gone away in terms of console space
right but i got the nes like the first
three months it was out i remember
buying zelda which one which one did you
have which one did you have the standard
base the one what was the standard okay
i didn't even i mean i wasn't i wasn't i
was a gamer i wanted to make movies but
i was also programming games but
i i i i was aware of like rob the robot
yeah
right but i was like i just you know
whatever um and i remember
that first year of the nes in america
was like
in you know instead of cabbage patch
kids or pokemon cards or whatever
the cartridges themselves it's like do
you have goonies do you have these two
you know and and do you have track and
field like all that launch suite of
games where there were like 20 of them
you know kids were like selling them on
the playground it was just like my mom
found you know i'm trying you know
gradius you have radius you know um and
it was great it was great and so i've
just always been a gamer uh
of arcade of pc and maybe that's why
these days
i don't have a lot of patience for
console war stuff not because i'm like
i'm better than you or anything but
because i'm like
it would have i grew up at a time where
it never would have occurred to me
to do anything but if i can't afford we
didn't have a lot of money it's like if
i can't afford a system
then i'm certainly going to seek it out
for my friend who has it yeah um because
i want to play everything you know i
just i i've i've always struggled with
that i get to kind of like
yeah you know you like alabama i like
all of your favorites right we're just
playing around but you know i've always
been stunned by the level of of of
vitriol yes because i'm like
aren't are you guys aren't kidding are
you no they they're serious with it but
that's like without the games man
not to interrupt you make it a fantastic
point because we kind of share that
error and you said it beautifully
earlier which is like we're from the era
like you say if your friend had the
idiot you had the nes but your friend
had the master system it was like hey
come over check this out jesus
he's blessing us yeah see we like to see
we let the white guy remember you said
we didn't let the white guys see it
so anyway
at the end of the
we come from that era and it was just
like it was just the sharing and the joy
of games because we all didn't come from
a lot of money and it was more so i was
broke then there was starting the trade
game so it's like all right let me hold
this like you said let me get the
greatest you got the pro wrestling okay
you got the mike tyson punch out cool or
let's be honest that was the days of
coming over someone's house that's right
right you go to your very trusting
friends
that's a different level but i'm sorry
to interrupt you jeff but i had i wanted
to stress that and i understand your
logic there so yeah i i yeah so i mean
it was always in my life i i'd come to
california to go to film school i never
got into film school i got into usc
i was an english major uh and i was i
was you know
i was gaming then constantly i was
supposed to be writing scripts which i
did but i would procrastinate by going
down to the 7-eleven and i would play
mortal kombat or i would play whatever
they had there
uh
you know i was playing sonic uh
my ex-wife who would come over all the
time
she would
i remember it
well no i'm just thinking because i'm
i'm like you know sometimes i would go
she'd come over and we were still early
dating and i didn't want her to hear me
go into the bathroom so i'd go into the
bathroom and i'd turn on the water or
whatever and when i i when i heard her
playing sonic i'm like okay she i can
take a [ __ ]
you're that level of love and
progression because now she's playing
sonic she's distracted i can come here
and get done can you relate
you know did that come out loud i don't
want her to hear me in here um so uh but
anyway yeah so and then i got to sony as
a tester i expected that to be a
relatively quick stopover because i had
sold some tv shows to a couple of
studios in la and hollywood and i expect
i didn't know you know i had one friend
who was a co-producer on the first show
that we sold and we were still in
college and he dropped out of college
took all of his fraternity brothers to
vegas uh took because he had the money
from his dad had already paid right so
when he dropped out he got all the money
that was left over that he had you know
because what had happened was like the
friday before we were doing a deal with
a company called new line television
which since which is now part of warner
brothers
and they said hey we're talking to oprah
winfrey about your show and they may
want to produce it and you'd have to
move to chicago and all this stuff and
it was just you know now you know that
that's just like
talk right but when you're 19 you're
like mom we're moving to chicago we're
going to work with oprah you know you
believe every single thing that they
tell you
and my buddy just
washed out because he was like i'm done
i don't need to be at school right
so
but so i get a job uh as a tester and uh
yeah that's that really the minute i got
in i was like you know all this creative
stuff i want to do
i can do in games uh because there's not
as frankly there's not as much
competition and i don't think i would
have i'm not as good of a writer
uh as i was working in games part of it
was because at the time i think
the competition for people who did what
i wanted to do just wasn't there right
so i could be a big fish and a it was a
big pond because it was sony's pawn but
in terms of those kind of games right um
and now you actually have real people
that want to be writers like i look at
corey barlog and that cory's a much
better writer than i ever was and ever
will be
but
i got in kind of where
the fact that i wanted to write and have
a character arc and i wanted to have
plot points and acts and and have
emotional resonance in the game play
that was enough to put me leagues ahead
of almost everybody else now you've got
people who genuinely like writing who
are in the process
once you get into the sony building
right you're in the sony building and
yeah this is uh what playstation one
right
well before we were at sony image soft
before playstation was even announced
you know terrible games like uh three
ninjas kick back
we had a couple of we had we had sky
blazer which was awesome we had equinox
that was awesome a couple of games
really worked um but yeah this was this
was beautiful building the sony music
building on colorado it looked like a
pirate ship we had a meeting room that
was a round table you guys as iron lords
i mean it was a beautiful huge round
table but it was made to look like a
compact disc because it was the sony
music building
though it looked like you were sitting
around a huge
cd
um
it was great but yeah so i started there
and then about a year after working
there
the sony japan people came in and showed
us a vhs tape of hey this is this thing
we're doing called playstation we're
going around to all the developers to
see if there's interest and we were like
oh my god it was amazing you made
you made the tren the transition from a
tester to a developer
yeah how that's the part that i'm trying
to get to so when you went inside and
then you saw postings and said you know
what i'm going to apply for this was it
that open of a field that you were able
to insert yourself into a position that
you wanted to get to so
how was the process i will well i'll
tell you the
there's the practical answer then
there's the important answer right the
practical answer is i was a tester
um
i knew
somehow it wasn't a very big company
first of all it was like at the time
sony imagesoft was probably
in the development side there was
probably like 15 of us right so
a guy who was just hired and test was
still every monday morning sitting
around the table with the producers the
marketing the head of the company
you know so it was it was a it was easy
to be noticed right
um the other part of it though was i had
heard that disney was looking for a
developer for
their mickey mouse game their 65th year
birthday
yeah and so and so
me and my buddy mike guillaume who went
on to design for sony uh warhawk and the
khan and uh
uh
and now he's over at jesse chanel games
doing like i expect you to die in those
vr games and stuff
um
we were like hey let's we love disney
and we love games we could do this and
so we just you know we went down to
blockbuster we rented a bunch of the the
disney movies and made our own little
style guide for the video and we we uh
got concept art and you know we and we
just you know we we just did it you know
and you know the bigger thing though
there is is um
[Music]
and i've told this story and i don't
mean to go on about it but i think it's
really important because out of all of
the people listening to your show today
and down the road
uh
it's important regarding i think getting
what you want and i think even watching
you know watching you guys like you're
saying
uh the people who showed up for your
fight podcast last night king that
they're they're allowing you to continue
to sort of pursue this thing that
clearly is your passion um there's a lot
of people who just stop
because the situation
hasn't presented itself it hasn't come
up and knocked on their door and said
come be a broadcaster come be a game
designer you know and i was sitting in a
theater at usc when jeffrey katzenberg
who's a very well-known movie executive
used to run disney animation everything
somebody raised their hand it was the
film school crowd they said hey i'm can
you tell me how to make it in hollywood
and he said he says it doesn't matter
what i say to you everybody who's
actually capable who wants to make it
they will find a way to make it they
will make their own path in
and so i think that's the bigger thing
is that i was i had other testers at
sony right i had producers at sony that
were like why is this guy
who just started six months ago getting
a shot to pitch disney and it's like
because he asked and he demanded it and
he stayed late and he pitched it and he
put together with mikey on a a pitch and
then he went to the head of the company
and he pitched it and had the company
liked it and now you're in the room you
know you only get in the room because
you walk in the room no one's going to
sing you an invite so
it's just like david like you guys said
first thing you said is we went to
blockbuster and got a bunch of the the
research material like like it's little
things like that you wanted to educate
yourself to actually do a pitch that
would that would entice them yeah it's
it's stuff like that because like you
know i feel like there's a lot of stuff
going on when it comes to especially
like tv show and stuff where they'll
make tv shows on media and don't even
care about the original source it it's
like you back then was caring about the
original source
but i i i will say what's important to
also remember is that you know a lot of
times when people hear
stories like that and whether it's a
motivational story or not i think it
depends on the person but
you know a lot of that
was driven out of fear a lot of that was
like i grew up without a lot of money i
would come home and my parents were
incredibly loving but you know sometimes
i'd come home and the power was off like
we did not have the money to pay the
power bill you know
and
you know a lot of what drives people
like i want to be driven like that it's
like you can be but everybody comes up
through their own kind of
uh
tunneling system and what they emerge
with is what they emerge with and that
one's not better than the other
it's just that's kind of what society
created in them and so
you can't necessarily teach that like i
remember i mean i know will smith these
days is kind of you know
on the chopping block but but you know
will smith for the longest time always
talked about that he was like you know
so much of what made me the hardest
working guy in the room was not because
anything is in my moral fiber makes me
better right i just didn't want to fail
because i knew the taste of failure and
i couldn't go back there that's a good
point and so it's you know it's
important to have those caveats
otherwise people just go you're a better
person than i am because i'm not like
they don't realize your beginnings and
your your remembrance of upset
beginnings yeah right i mean like you
said the lights is off those those type
of situations like i i grew up in a a
very very poor neighborhood right we
didn't even know that we was poor but
because
like you said one person had a nintendo
somebody had a turbo graphics and we all
would link and we will all play and we
will all have those conversations yeah
you had your preference but at the same
time we understood that in this poverty
we grew together and that grew strength
in us so you seeing these opportunities
in front of you
you knew you you were hungry and you
wanted to take care of your business
right that's right that was the pure
motivation behind it so i actually love
the fact that i wanted to get to the
part where you came in as a tester and
you're pitching
your game to disney because i definitely
wanted to talk about the mickey mouse
everybody talks about god of war but
they don't ever talk about mickey mouse
man
so
is that me or you that might be can you
get shot let's go get us mean
you did get it but it's a good point
because you know also speaking something
into existence as opposed to like
especially taking your shot right yeah i
feel like that's a big deal because some
you could have people who are qualified
in the room who want something but then
it's also the the next step was the
initiative to say hey to let whoever
know i really want this and here's my
presentation that that extra initiative
you know that is what we call it like
speaking it into existence off you know
what i'm saying that kind of thing i
think that's important
there's a lot of it's all there is
there's nothing else
no absolutely absolutely so i think
where king was going as far as like you
now you make the pitch like your
experience because that being kind of
like your first
real picture that you kind of get it
with mickey minnie like describe that
experience now well okay but i had been
pitching tv shows and movies right
i had experience i knew what it was like
to walk into
[Music]
you know ron howard studio or i i had
gone into spielberg's studio and pitched
his uh first in command and then oh it
was so amazing we went into amblin uh
and i was a massive film nerd and i
remember we did everything spielberg did
so me and my film buddies snuck off the
trams uh walked the back lot met people
you know it was insane i
uh uh and and so
but eventually i got invited to amblin
to pitch this tv show which ironically
was about virtual reality um and this is
before virtual reality had become what
it is today it was about these cops that
patrolled the cyber world whatever um
and
it was it
it it i was so
uh
i had so mythologic mythology what's the
word not i i what's the verb mythologize
i had so mythologized
movie makers and uh spielberg
specifically bob zemeckis specifically
that just being in that thing felt like
it was it was spiritual yeah but then
you know and that's maybe one of the
reasons i push back so much on a lot of
the press stuff now
is because i i got that experience of
learning that these are obviously but to
me
i held them in such reverences
and then when i met them or met people
like them
i was like oh this is it i don't mean
that disrespectfully but i'm just like
you know there was a great evening that
occurred where we all i was just like
you're just this guy and the media and
your pr has turned you into something
and that's why a lot of people like why
are you always so brutally honest or
whatever doesn't mean that's a good
thing or a bad thing depends on the
topic but because i don't want to put on
fronts in my social media world because
i think it's very unhealthy and i think
people pick up on it and they're just
like but but anyway the point is so yes
i was pitching i was going to tell you i
went to amblin and spielberg has had i
don't know what they have anymore uh an
arcade underneath in the basement and i
was just i was in heaven i got to go to
spielberg's company i got to pitch
spielberg my show not him but although i
didn't meet him
earlier and uh and then i got together
like oh yeah you want to see the arcade
i'm like yeah yeah and so they took us
down there all the games were free brand
new games it was awesome but yeah so i
had experience pitching
before mickey mania but yes when we did
mickey mania it was
amazing because we pitched the lion king
and mickey mania they came in saying we
have two properties
um
well and and what ended up happening was
you know we pitched mickey mania we
practiced the crud out of mickey look at
me
[Music]
um and you still gotta depart i mean
across yeah yeah
well
trust me you still had that punch okay
but but but yeah we practiced tons on
that pitch right so it wasn't just like
yeah i mean it was we were there until
like three in the morning
it was crazy let's go and we got around
a round of applause from a bunch of
disney executives after a pitch from a
tester that they didn't know i was a
tester um
that was a moment that was awesome you
know
um and and so they were like yeah okay
you guys
can do it yeah um and it was uh and from
from then on
there were a lot of struggles because i
didn't know what the heck the job was
that i was in i had really wrong
expectations about what it meant to make
a video game and i almost lost my career
because i had those expectations and it
took me a while to understand
you know what it meant to direct and
what it meant to creatively lead um and
i still you know i'm still was not never
great at it from a personnel standpoint
um
but yeah so that's how i kind of got in
and got it with mike and the team super
impressive okay it gets off question
dave like um was there any because now
there's a different pressure attached to
anything that belongs to disney right
you have star wars and marvel there's a
different level of pressure attached to
it but back then you know 94 is when
mickey mania i think came out
before then you had castle of illusion
which was a big hit and then i think you
had fantasia in the middle the one that
we loved was it was a sega genesis co-op
with donald and mickey yeah which was
like a side scroller it takes two before
it takes two yeah yeah i just thought it
was so clever that it was like we're
doing different things in order to
progress i forget which that one was
called but that was the that was the one
that i was i love the most absolutely
and was there any sort of in your pitch
was there any
pushback from the execs like hey we need
this to be as good as these games
oh yeah because if there was
something new i i why they i i have to
assume image
soft busted their butts to get disney to
show up because it wasn't like we were
on the top
of anyone's list it's like hey we could
go over to capcom again who did
castlevolusion or what about the guys
who worked on the dracula sega cd and
sewer shark games yeah let's go talk to
them that was us right um wait you
worked on shark well i was a tester on
it for about a week uh okay okay okay
yeah um
but uh uh
but but yeah so i i don't think there
was
we
we had so much pressure on ourselves
that every game we thought we were
making
star wars you know so as much as i and
that's the other thing i mean as much as
i i love disney now because i had my
kids and
now they've kind of outgrown a lot of it
i hope they come back but because i took
them all the time i became a total
disney head that i never was before but
i was kind of like i like mickey mouse
enough
it's like
mickey mouse was a trapeze that came to
my career and i said i'll take that yes
um and that's i mean it could have been
it could have been strawberry shortcake
i didn't care you got to get to take the
shot yeah right um and so
uh there was pressure but there was
pressure that we put on ourselves
because we really wanted to
[Music]
make something
really cool like mike and i both were
like very big believers in the medium
and we're like this is not
little this doesn't have to just be
jumping bop on people's head mascot
games there's there's something here
i remember
i mean this is crazy i remember and part
of its delusions of grandeur but i
remember
going back to my apartment in culver
city i was just a tester or maybe i was
out a test as a
assistant producer whatever it was after
test
and i had taken a laptop home that they
had assigned me and i remember again
this goes back to the toilet i was
sitting on the toilet um with my laptop
so never borrow my laptop
i'm sitting on the toilet with my laptop
and i remember just journaling and i was
like i i i remember writing this it was
just like you know i think
i'm going to be somebody meaningful in
this business like there was something
in my brain back then that made me go
the decision i'm in the right i'm in the
right yeah i'm in the right i'm in the
right place at the right time and i
recognize and and that that's happened
to me a couple of times in my life one
was when i met my
just like a little voice of like just
you're good you're good right here
another one was like when i i met my
wife uh at the time and had a disaster
you know she's now the mom of my kids uh
disastrous first date that she didn't
even realize was a date that's how bad
it was
you was on a date yeah that's right
yeah she may as well have just been like
i'm going down to pick up some pants
there's this guy with me and he's
sticking around you know
um
but i remember getting out of her car
because she drove um because i didn't
have a car it was la
and uh
and i remember that same voice going
don't get out i know this was a bad
experience for you
don't get out of this car
and and not call her again because she's
gonna be very important in your life
i don't know
i don't i'm not a religious guy at all
at all
um i don't believe that was anything
like a you know i i don't know and it
wasn't by the way
yeah because i want to be clear it
wasn't like
when i look back i've kind of remapped
that story because it wasn't you know i
i get how the brain can do that this was
in those moments one of them when i was
journaling about it wasn't like i was
journaling about it eight months after
right at the moment you know so
i don't know when it comes to video
games i had a sense at the time that
this was the place for me just like now
i have a sense that it's not the place
for me this is the place for me right
now we're going to get that we're going
to get yeah i want to i want to
transition quickly um
into sony santa monica and obviously you
know the god of war and my question
first is like
while this creative process is going on
like
did you did the team know
you guys had something at that are you
talking about with god of war yes
okay so it depends on who you're talking
about with me
um
i knew
that there were days where i thought we
were making the next star wars
i i thought we were on to something even
though it wasn't working
but sometimes those days the same day
i thought we were screwed
i i thought
this is done you know you don't get to
know like even with twisted metal
uh i had one of the most disastrous
focus tests of my life um
the very first focus test i ever had
and they had brought in a bunch of
hardcore street fighter fans to play
warhawk and twisted metal and they loved
warhawk and they just thought twisted
metal was the stupidest thing in the
world and so everybody left that meeting
i thought my career was over marketing
was going to put all their money behind
warhawk and
well you know i what am i going to do
now i guess i'll go back to movies or
something yeah where's warhawk though
well i know
you know we didn't know any better and
so um
with god of war was very similar i i the
the story i remember specifically was
i i had gone we were working in santa
monica i had gone to santa monica place
which is a mall there was an eb there or
a game spot or whatever i don't know
what it was one of those
and if you guys remember they had the uh
the dummy boxes like eight months six
months five months before the actual
game would ship and so i walked in it
was like lunch so i went in around one
o'clock and i saw the god of war box for
the first time
and it was surrounded i forget whatever
i know like um
[Music]
there was a couple other games that hit
around the same time fantastic four from
the movie was one there was all the
boxes were there and i remember just
going this doesn't fit i'm like this is
not gonna work no one's gonna come into
the store and buy that game i'm like
we're so dead in the water but
i stayed late that night working with uh
the designer producer whitney wade and
todd pappy who directed ascension and
then he's now over on the the starter
what's the big expensive star game from
chris roberts uh
that they've raised crazy money for that
hasn't come out yet
he's working on that now but but we were
working it was like three in the morning
and todd went to the bathroom whitney
was smoking i don't know i was just in
the office by myself for a few minutes
and there was a giant kratos image that
we had blown up and framed and put on
the wall
and in the same day of coming from eb
and going we're screwed this is a total
failure the box doesn't fit when i
looked up at three in the morning x
hours later i was like we have the next
star wars
and so within one day i was
peaking and crashing all day long
because you just don't know and then i
remember shannon came to me and i won't
tell you the person's name because he's
still very active and i talked to him
but but she said hey um
this guy was up in my office and he just
doesn't see the game and we were both
like oh man because he's one of the
hardest core gamers and
shucks we're dead you know shucks
this is this is the stuff that i wanted
i just want one real question
so so we're like we're dead um and then
but you know four months later he's back
and he's like whoa i played the whole
game this week and it was awesome
so
to answer your question no one
you don't know what you have you have
moments where you recognize a massive
failure in moments where you recognize
uh
brilliance
and so in a lot of ways it's kind of
like that part and god of war the first
god of war with the desert the lost
souls where you're following the voices
of the sirens all you can really do
is is is is is grab on to that north
star that is that core vision
and just go i'm gonna be surrounded by
chaos for the next three years as we
make this and so is the rest of the team
right and so is as long as i can hold on
to that north star
i don't know if it'll be good or bad but
that's all i can do because everything
else is out of my control because
there's too many moving parts to have a
conscious awareness of how it's all
working right
then i gotta follow up the question is
um just the medal came first before the
god of war right it did yeah okay
um and how did it feel that you you
tapped in
to their edge
you were that demographic that uh what
is it this the 16 the 25 year old
demographic yeah that they're they're
dying to get because you know you're
looking at paraphernalia rapper and uh
other kitty stuff that there was just
flash or you know no warhawk was you
know a nice game like like i said but
twisted metal had an edge to it yeah god
of war has an edge to it so you
really crafted
their their their their identity
because yeah that's what made
playstation hip
took it away from nintendo's language it
was kitty uh sega was hit but
playstation was edgy yes
and you made them well okay
yeah but even at even at e3 94 or the
very first e3 95 before twisted ship
yeah seeing how sony was marketing the
playstation it was clear that they
they were doing a lot of the heavy
lifting on let's make this cooler let's
make this edgier
certainly the games i got to work on
helped with that movement there were
certainly other ones i mean even to
shinden that looked cool
let's go yeah if you launch that and you
compare that to something very kind of
nintendo we people are like that's a
dominatrix with the whip
and doing the big mallet yeah yeah
everybody i'm like that's not nintendo
you know um so
part of but but yeah certainly twisted
metal uh was was up there with the
others kind of going this is not your
because when you read the bio sweet
tooth and these other characters that's
inside these games yeah um i'm i'm sorry
but it doesn't
it didn't read like how a normal video
game would read yeah was that your
background in movie making and stuff
like that because you saw possibilities
for larger different type of franchises
that came from these games
absolutely
i just wanted to say that you crafted
this this these identities how did it
feel going did you have that pressure
because i don't know if you knew it the
the the numbers on twisted metal was
pretty really good right it had to be
really good well back then we were
praying to sell over a hundred thousand
copies because that's back in the super
nintendo days if you sold 100k you were
like holy cow you know right yeah
and i think you know i know we only
spent 850 000 i mean that's less than i
paid for my house since
i mean it it's insane um and it went on
to make i i you know i don't know how
many it sold now but when it was full
price on ps1 it definitely got
if it didn't get to a million it got
very very close to a million at full
price and then it means selling and
things like that so yeah it was you know
yeah um is it true i have two
behind-the-scenes questions on both
games first with twisted metal oh is it
true
that you part of the
conceptual aspect of it was you sitting
in traffic like in la
[Music]
guns and we could just shoot them
isn't that part of the concept yes yes
it was it was it was it was coming back
from evans and sutherland who became
single track and if you if you like
pixar and you follow
uh the pixar story a lot of the guys
from ens that were doing evans helen
that were doing military sims
a bunch of them broke off and became
pixar with ed catmull and all those guys
but a bunch of them broke off and became
single track which was the entertainment
division that ens wanted but they
changed their mind so these guys said
well screw it we're going to go off and
make our own thing with sony and you
know so we had come back from utah it
was the first time we had seen actual 3d
i was flying through three databases and
military sims so me and alan becker and
brian wicklund and mike young were all
in the cab it was back in the day with
cabs um you're right and we're stuck in
the traffic and it's like yeah we're
just like
my god all i want to do is blow these
cars away um
like mad max style and there was just a
light bulb moment you know for all of us
and then i just i found
it's somewhere over there but i found
about seven months ago when i was going
through all my old documentation uh
because we did a stream about the 25th
anniversary of playstation and i found
the document or not even a document it's
literally a piece of notebook paper
that's half ripped now where i wrote we
were going into a marketing meeting
around that giant cd-rom table at sony
music and i wrote like seven ideas for a
playstation game i wanted to make right
and one of them says like um
battle cars in city mad max and that was
based on the visit to evans other ones
and so the actual
first written idea of of twisted metal i
actually have and i found it i was like
oh that's so cool that that still exists
but but yeah i mean when i and i went
into marketing they were in the going
around the table going what do you want
to make what do you want to make and
marketing didn't have a green light but
they were important to have their buy-in
and they got to me and i said oh i want
to do this thing called battle cars it's
basically doomed with cars in a city
they're like done
that was it
that was the green light i mean
i
i
hit that industry at exactly the right
time for what i was able to contribute
that's why a lot of people are
stunned about why aren't you still in
games i'm like i had my
and i don't mean that like i'm done with
my ambition but in terms of that realm
right
i i
hit such a sweet spot
of my ambition for storytelling my
limits of how good of a storyteller i
could be and what the medium could do
um how much i was willing to put up with
corporate bs
whereas now to get a green light
no
i would not jump through your hoops i
mean you know
my time at sony was
uh uh like being on a writer's
commune or or something where it was
just like jaffee what do you want to
make
i want to make this
that that's a little out there i don't
want to spend that kind of money but 95
percent of what i wanted to make they're
like okay oh you know everything was a
go back day like yeah that was good
not for everyone not for everyone
somebody did a picture of my boss
um who greenlit this stuff and
he he was and remains very zen and stuff
and he's in like these like monk robes
and he's got this
stone in his hand and he's like i will
give you a green light if you can figure
out how to remove the stone from my hand
so for a lot of people for a lot of
people it was
impossible
but i was i was plugged into what the
audience wanted i was plugged into how
to sell it at sony i i i just
you know it's like being on a hot streak
at the casino
and i enjoyed it i felt at home i was
in love with that part of the work
and then i wasn't and
we gonna get to that point we gonna get
to that point okay yeah yeah but before
we get there get out of here
this god of war situation right here
this god of war situation right yeah
here we go
for
what you crafted at this point in time
right with the team
let me ask my question before you start
getting into the newer stuff
i do have a quick question john if you
like when it comes to i know
when it comes to like the the higher ups
at the studios and and the people below
them there's like a back and forth on
creative uh direction was ever a time
when you was making any of the god of
wars where your people wanted something
so bad or you wanted something so bad
and there's a lot of fight back and
the the result ended up making the game
better
all the time
all of the time every game i've said
this before every game i've worked on
that's been a fight has been has worked
uh every game i've worked on that's been
easy
not easy to make but like a very
friendly environment uh has been like eh
you know calling all cars was the most
fun game to ever work on
um but
you know
i there should have been fights there
there should have been me saying to that
team
even though there are some religious
people on your team and there were right
that didn't want the presentation that i
originally wanted for calling all cars
which was very r-rated very arcrum
underground comics a lot of there was
nudity there was alcohol there was pot
it was meant to be kind of like a a
subversive kind of cartoon
um
and they pushed back
and i was like well i want to be a nice
guy because i just started this company
with scott and
uh i have this reputation for being
difficult because of god of war okay
we'll get into that and the game yeah
and the game comes out and the game
tanks and the game tanks not because
it's not great ign which i you know
have a hate love affair with uh you know
said it was playstation's uh geometry
wars i mean there were a lot of good
reviews of that game people today still
tell me they like that game but
thematically
nobody who just bought a 600 playstation
3
is going to run out and buy a game that
looks like it was made for
five-year-olds yeah um and i should have
pushed back and i didn't and there you
go you know so
uh but yeah there was a lot of there was
always fighting on god of war um it
always helped
i i found an email that shannon studs
still wrote to me who was the producer
and then she went on to run the studio
and this was um i don't remember when
she wrote me this it was after god of
war
and and she was just like letting me
know she's like nobody wants to work
with you
break it down break it down yeah i mean
i'll send you the email you can put on
your show
but to read it now
after you know when i got it i was like
do you know who i am i don't mean that
like it was a flexible like dave wasn't
flexing but i'm like okay all the stuff
that you're saying shannon that
is a problem is what got us god of war
right it's like i could have come in and
been the friend to everybody but i
wanted to only be the friend of the
player all i cared about was the player
everybody else was secondary
and then that was great because that was
shannon's job to worry about them it was
my job to worry about the player only it
was like being a bodyguard and i'm like
dude we have to do this for the player
you know and but but it really did come
at a cost and i think um and i i don't
regret it but to read that email now
how do you take it now
it it's it makes me sad um but i do i
wouldn't have changed anything but
um
[Music]
because i didn't know any better
and that was the only way i knew
how to get what was in my head
across into the game and then have the
team take it and take it to 20 levels
above what i had and so are there other
ways to do it sure but i was like 30
years old i had never run internal
development before and that's you know
so sony and we'll save it for the xbox
part but sony
sony
a few years before god of war was
basically where xbox is now in regards
to how they know how to run internal
development
um and so no one knew
hey we have this guy who's really
creative really passionate really driven
but he's out of his mind
um and and we didn't have anybody like
we had mark cerny that you could say hey
mark the team in san diego making
baseball struggling with this thing
on the hardware go down there for a
couple of days and help them we didn't
have anybody who knew how to deal
with creative management and go how do
we take someone who's incredibly
valuable
and make sure he can still express what
he needs to to give the company what
they need
without making the team literally want
to
they'd rather go work at a sweatshop in
china
god of war fun facts i need to know if
this is true if i know some people who
work with you in the past
god of war we got snitches i got some
stuff
so god of war from what i heard was was
known to at one point have a fairy in a
jar yes
is this true this is well it was in the
design we you know everything gets cut
into the inch of its life because you
you got to make your date and stuff for
the most well once
all right um
so um but yeah
yeah yeah but it was in the design and
um
it was basically going to be just like a
like
kratos the very beginning would have
like a little fairy like navi and zelda
and but he's like what is this thing
it wasn't his friend they just got sent
to him by athena
and and she's like hey listen come over
here here's how the door works
like
oh my god he was just gonna kill it and
just like you know i hate you shut up
and so that was the idea like a tutorial
star would have been cool you know it
would have been cool jaffy if you gave
the player the option like she would be
your narrator the whole game but you
could kill her at the beginning and not
hear anything yeah okay it's interesting
you bring that up because we had me and
alex stein one of the writers we had a
number of conversations excuse me about
you know
how much agency do we give the player to
reflect kratos character right so there
was another puzzle where we did have
that conversation about do we want to
let
you have another way of pushing the guy
in the cage into the fire pit at the top
of the hill
and alex and i were like on one hand
that would make for cool gameplay
but it doesn't help establish this
character kratos is not whoever you want
him to be kratos is kratos and you
happen to be controlling his avatar and
so i as a one-off i appreciate what you
said your idea but it really was a
something we struggled with for a couple
of months alex and i about you know
on one hand you want to make an iconic
character
that has personality and on the other
hand you want to give the player freedom
and where is that line because too much
freedom and you end up with the
character like in elden ring which is
one of my probably my favorite game of
all time if not my top three but
nobody would
you know what's my character i don't
know right you know it's not there's no
right which is part of its strength so
okay so all right good i'm glad that you
said that part right because you made uh
an icon
in terms of the stuff that we was
watching like you know 80s and 90s stuff
we grew up on bruce willis die hard you
know yeah watching egg stuff and all
that in all the horror movies you know
yeah grind house stuff like that right
so and and and going into god of war you
were tapping into that that 18 26 year
old that's more like 14 to 2 okay
younger you know yeah and then you had
you know a little nudity and stuff in
there but and the blood
and the jump button shout out to the
jump button all right here we go here we
go
why would you jump
not my god award and this is not his his
voice
love 2018 but yeah it's definitely not
great it's not the same game
i honestly think in my heart and and i'm
i'm going to say it on the episode
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah absolutely i know
i i listen great game yep it's not god
of war that's right i think so right
because they took
that character this this character that
and this is me the player okay get your
balls in love with this this alpha male
that walks in the room baddest dude in
the room 100
motivations is the kick butt gets the
gods back for what happened right
beautiful stuff great set pieces
everything's fantastic now you got this
guy that want to be alone
you want to be left alone he wants to be
the incredible hulk he's bill bixby all
of a sudden
the thing is though king i will say that
i feel like the reason that it feels
that way is like he achieved his goals
he killed the people that ruined his
life like where did you expect him to go
do you stay angry like i don't know
you know
the character is made up of that right
you don't lose that edge what they did
was soften it made it more palatable for
what's available now
i have to say it was probably an
impossible situation though because you
know it was clear
from the sales of ascension
that at least at that time
traditional god of war was no longer
making it worse
yeah i mean i think everybody did and i
think what corey ended up doing you know
even though i i
the older i get the more distance i get
from it as much as i love 2018 i do find
some of the press response to it
disrespectful and unseemly and
and i get very bothered by it the older
i get um but
what corey did i thought was incredibly
smart and incredibly interesting both in
terms of being able to read where the
audience and the medium was for that
game because i think they enjoyed
the sense of a game that reflected back
to them that they had grown and they
were no longer the 10 year old sneaking
god of war 2005 and seen titties for the
first time
they were like oh i'm growing big boy
now
you know and
even though i think all of that's very
silly and actually psychologically
reflective of someone who hasn't grown
right you know it's kind of like the
more you front and tell me you're a
mature person the less i believe right
but but but that aside though i think
that was incredibly smart from a
marketing standpoint of corey and i also
think it was a really neat
story
of like what happens when
the anti-hero
has time to reflect right right you know
there's nothing about that that i don't
applaud and go i could have never come
up with that i love that right but it's
still not right god of war
you know it's still it still doesn't
negate king is so happy the fact that um
boobs and blood and sex and violence and
all those things that you love in horror
movies and heavy metal magazine and in
in metal albums and whatever
all that stuff is still
viable respectful fun and and has a
place in people's uh psyches and i i i
got very bothered by the fact that it
was like
you haven't you've just shoved it in a
hole
because you think you're doing what
society wants you to do but in truth
that's going to come out in a lot of
ways
you better be careful good at it i do
agree with you like the biggest
disappointment like i'm not too much on
to the story thing because i think
naturally that makes sense as a
progressive thing
i'm more upset with god war because of
like the lack of gore
because i feel like in the center of god
of war that's what was there
and the willingness to do anything and
everything to these bosses and i feel
like that was single-handedly the
biggest thing that was not there that
should have been there yeah the
brutality yeah
yeah people always ask me that if you
were to make the if you were to have
made 2018
i would have had sex in it i would have
had gore in it um i would have liked to
have thought jump button
oh yeah
sem
it would have had it had a happy
because you know i i've been on that
square for so long you know and people
get upset with i can't it's it's a good
game right
it's a good game but it just wasn't what
my space was what what i was uh you know
like trained up on
violence sex and and and and it was not
overt sex so let's let's stop acting
like it was overt the violence
let's stop acting like it was
misogynistic it was yeah it was it was
you know he has a threesome in the first
four minutes of the game
but they were willing they were they
were uh they signed a consent form
you got to remember too like what what
part uh like
the age it was you know was in the
mythology and stuff like that was going
down all the time we got 900
today
do something it's always going down all
the time that's what's funny about it
it's just like
let me ask you this let me answer this
jeffy it refers to that like now that
you've seen you know something that you
really integral with you know including
you know god why interest a bit like in
any official or unofficial capacity
has anyone ever reached out to you for
direction on god war or just input on
anything during that process
which process let's say 2018 let's start
with 2018.
no no shannon and i
were on the alps for a very long time
after i left eatsly play okay
and it was one of the most
heartbreaking
experiences because she really
means a great deal to me both as a
colleague and as a friend and and we
just
we we couldn't see eye to eye on some
very important things um
and we've since reconciled which makes
me very very happy but but so i wasn't
i wasn't
engaged with her
uh
you know and i was very busy uh
uh
building my own stuff and so
it really wasn't on my radar and even
though i know people have said that
shannon has said in the press that they
did reach out to me before corey
you know
i must i must have missed the email
because
i have the email where she said nobody
wants to work with me i still have that
one but i don't have the one that says
hey come make god a war so i feel that
that's real and the follow-up to it was
that and i got your kick i know you
limited i do want to follow up in
reference to you know reflecting looking
back your time there and how sometimes
there's that push-pull with the creation
of really great games
my question to you is you know i've
heard your data collection it's kind of
stuff of legend in terms of like
you know you would kind of go with every
member of the team so like in a scale of
110
what do we feel about this this weapon
here what do we feel about this so like
break that down in your mindset with
that with every aspect of the game it
wasn't every aspect but it was you know
you you
all i know is you are
or at least the way i felt about it is
there were certain things i knew
i knew the tone of the game i knew
what i wanted the player to feel like
that that never changed if you go back
and look at the original design document
which i've given to fans over the years
when it was called dark odyssey the very
first line is uh you know what would
clash the titans be like if paul
verhoeven had directed it now most
people today don't know who paul
verhoeven is so i changed it to ridley
scott but paul verhoeven did starship
troopers and robocop and uh robot was
brutal
he did a bunch of
live coming with me yeah he did a bunch
of very violent oh total recall i'll buy
that for a dollar yeah
that was much doing it and so that was
always
never wavered
that's right um clarence
that yo that is so iconic yeah this is
this is the space that you're in because
you're in that space so
it's just it's just weird to talk and
you translated that space over this is
what this is why i was so successful
because you actually translated that
feel that space over what we were living
in and i can understand the turn in 2018
for what they wanted to do because the
times have changed we have progressively
so-called moved on but you don't
discount what came before it and you
don't say we matured past what this is
because right that's not the case that's
what got you where you are
but but but but yeah i mean so um
what was your question i was so
basically about the the data the data
gathering oh yeah so so i knew what the
north star was from the very beginning
but
when you're going through that desert
you need all the help you can get
whether that's creative help from the
team going i had an idea and you're like
oh my god that's brilliant put that in
uh or
whether it's just like i think these
three three things are cool i'm too
close what do you think so yeah i loved
getting feedback
uh of just gut reaction i didn't i
didn't i didn't need a write-up i didn't
need an email i'm like here's a picture
of who kratos could be here's a picture
one to ten one to ten cool things and
i'd move on i sort of old pictures thank
god you ain't pick one of the bubble
designs oh lord that was about to go one
with the helmet
yeah we spent uh over a year
with multiple artists under terry smith
and then charlie nguyen
um
trying to find
this character uh it was a you know
a huge endeavor it was a huge endeavor
um and and so yeah i was one detaining
all the time and then i'll tell you what
when we did play tests when they'd come
into santa monica
you can best believe those forms were
like how was this one to 10.
and i went home on a cloud of of
rarefied air when the final one was rate
the game on a scale of one to ten and
what chances would you buy this and when
those were in the nines and tens which
they were wow i was like
oh my god this is the greatest day ever
you said you worked with a lot of
artists to find out the final design for
kratos um was there any after that or
did you eventually come back to that one
after they showed you other ones no no
no one once
once
we kind of had the ed norton epiphany
um in the american history x epiphany
and then charlie
charlie did the art
in that
with that guidance
and i saw it i'm like oh
that that's a goal you know and a lot of
artists get frustrated the good concept
artists don't like some of the concept
artists would be like i would go to them
and a lot of this was because i was a
kid growing up learning how to make
movies so i would see the star wars
concept art of
droids or creature cantina characters or
whatever and it was sometimes like i
think it was uh was it ralph marquand or
whoever their famous concept artist was
but he would sometimes just fill a page
with rough sketches of like could be
this shape could be you know and that's
what i wanted i'm like i don't know and
they're like well he doesn't know what
he wants i'm like no
i don't know what i want i know i have a
feeling right but i'm not an artist but
i'm not going to come to you concept
artist you're i mean the the job title
is in the ti the job is in the title
concept artist part of it is it's a
collaboration i can come to you and give
you the emotion i can give you the
feeling i can show you examples of how
it makes me feel in movies and comics
but i can't say i want the eyes this
that you know you're not a police you're
not a police sketch artist
you know it's like
let's figure this out so honestly in a
lot of ways you go well how come you
took so long when all it was was that
simple thing i'm like because that's how
long it took yeah for the brain for my
particular brain
to be able to put the pieces together
and
there you go you know but that's how it
works soft and god king before you move
on to a final question no no i just it's
interesting because when you look at
this
all of those little details at any point
in time could change
the arc of this game the arc of this of
this
and they did
that that was the most fascinating part
to me that i just thought was the
neatest thing which was
um
[Music]
a technical limitation led to story
story led to art art led to story story
led to technical limitations it was like
we were all
swimming in this
cake i don't know cake batter of of what
god of war would become
and it was changing like i mean the
story i tell a lot is like i mean
whether it's his chain blades
which did not come from some great
creative epiphany it came from one of
our designers joe wright trying to
figure out how do we make kratos stand
out because the camera's pulled back so
far
and i showed her shinobi on the ps2
which had the long red scarf
yeah and i said we need something like
that
she's like well how about we could have
him have chains that would flow and we
could put particles on them and we would
no matter how far the camera is because
we wanted a cinematic camera
we would see kratos that's where that
came from oh god it was fine
the white skin on kratos came from
charlie nguyen having a technique which
i didn't know artists used which is he
would almost he would put like a primer
so he was like the white character with
the white oh here we go well okay well
it was it was originally the first time
i ever saw him it was written on like a
piece of sort of brown cardboard looking
colored paper so it was a black and
white image so there was no question of
his skin
but he was stark white and i said oh
that's really striking and charlie's
like no no i haven't painted him yet
that's just sort of a primer i put down
and i paint on top of it so the paint
sticks i don't know art but that's good
and i was like no no that's that's
amazing right right and so that gave
birth to
the story ashes and gabe you know and
that was just me walking over at the
time so how did you
[Laughter]
the good news is now after this you've
achieved your goal
you can stop with it just for men
we're not going to do that until
actually that date so i'm like but
that's the microsoft
all right so
uh the character has the white ash on it
with the brown skin under and it has uh
well
he's
okay if we're really talking about this
because i know some people have they
have it yes okay well
they say what what race is kratos right
and my answer is and this is probably an
ignorant answer but i based him off what
greek people in the greek isles and
greek movies look like in hollywood
that's all so i was like he's an olive
skin guy i guess he's a greek guy living
on the islands of some island off the
coast of or somewhere around sparta i
mean sparta's island too i think but it
you know and he's just like some olive
skin guy so it wasn't he wasn't an
african guy right everyone everyone's an
african guy but exactly in terms of
especially back then where we came from
but
ultimately though
that's all he was
i never thought about it other than
going he's like you know in a movie if
you saw a bunch of greek people running
around they wouldn't hire people
here we go
maybe maybe the greek people would be
stealing lord addicts potatoes
but
you know
they're always after me potatoes
you're basically a pot of gold away from
being the lucky charms guy oh god
hey irish is awesome but i mean you got
the you got the red hair
you got the the pale skin and i have
pale skin too i'm not mocking you and
you've got the red and yellow shirt
that's very irish leprechauns red and
yellow
my thought is always that uh he was um
of a darker descent and then when he
woke up his hair was his hair was a wool
and his
no actually i just well i thought he was
of a darker shade
right but he woke up in 2018 without a
jump button and he was a little bit
lighter
try to sneak in that last time somebody
should make a poster with that like the
white men can't jump
[Laughter]
what you do is you just put my avatar on
it
yeah put mine on it because i'm just
like we just want to transition so now
like you know you're moving on from that
i just want to talk about like
moving on from game development and now
kind of transitioning into like the
content creator space and
youtube and stuff like that and then you
know definitely one of the more candid
and opinionated content creators out
here with your respect you know what led
you to that decision and like how did
you find your joy in that cause you go
hard gavin and games is out here you're
doing live streams you know you're in
england with a lot of big content
creators like you know how did that
passion develop
so
when we were doing
like okay so draw draw you know drawn to
death was a failure uh
critically commercially um
and it's not
that i handled failure poorly like i
don't like failing i'm done
it was the fact that
i had put the same level of love and
attention and passion into that game
that i put into all my other games
and when i was like oh
this is no longer what they want from me
this is no longer you know uh
this isn't connecting i'm no longer
plugged in so part of it was like going
you you felt like you know the green
lantern's battery was out of juice and
it wasn't
and
it would be like it's all if i worked my
butt off
um i could come back from this failure
uh i could build another team i could
get back on the radar of people
um
and all i would if everything went
perfect
i would simply be back where i was it's
like i've been to that i've been to
everest right a couple of months
i've hung out at everest a couple of
times and i was like do i really have
the energy and the desire to fly all
over raising money and sit at my table
and pull out my hair for months on end
trying to figure out game play and story
and what's going to be sexy and cool in
a pitch meeting and all that and so i
started down that road thinking okay
well that's what i am that's who i am
um
but i kept having these remembrances of
like after drawn to death failed we had
a couple of games we were doing it at
bartlett jones right and i just i you
know my my wife her ex-wife at the time
said um
because i'd come home some days and i
would tell her
she's like what'd you do at work and i'm
like you know i sat up in the loft
because we had a loft
i said you know i did my work i got it
done i said but i couldn't wait to get
back up to the loft and just watch
videos of this guy who lives in a small
cabin in canada
and
he makes he makes he goes out in the
middle of the snow
uh in this one room cabin and he's got a
little stove and he brings his kindle
and uh it's like he's living in the in
the 1800s um and he just cooks biscuits
and i'm like
that's what i wanted to do you know
that's what i wanted you know i didn't
so there was this dawning awareness of i
think i was done another one was this
great animator we had hired a guy named
jeremiah who we were doing this game and
the characters in the game had these jet
packs and
there was this whole discussion about
when they hover and then land you know i
wanted it to be an instant piece of
gameplay i don't want you to have to go
through this animation of landings
because it's not you know it's not uh uh
responsive enough right and we had a
conversation about okay well what should
that look like and i remember being in
that meeting and just going i don't care
i don't
care i'm supposed to care but i don't
care you know and and so
then the company falls apart
and i'm home and and i expected i really
had this romanticized view of
i was just going to go walk on the beach
and i was going to cry
and i was just going to let it all out
and mourn it for like a month and then i
was going to get my crap together look
at me um get my crap together
crying for the realization that uh that
that fire that that was no longer no no
it wasn't that i wasn't aware of that it
was more i thought i was going to mourn
this great creative loss that no one
liked and i loved and what is what is
wrong with me and what you know and i
just thought okay prep for that let's do
that that's healthy you know if you need
to go to therapy let's get some therapy
people thought when i said that to phil
spence the other day i was being like a
jerk i believe in therapy i've been in
therapy on and on i have covets
didn't come like the closest i ever got
was at the time netflix had a show a
reboot of a show from when i was a kid
called one day at a time
and i was watching that and every now
and then that would make me cry and i'm
like is this it is this a starter it
never came and i was like i'm not sad
i'm kind of happy i'm kind of relieved
relieved right and then i realized it's
like i i had a memory of um
when we first started bartlett jones
i had a buddy of mine in the industry
say because we used to do these like
behind the scenes videos
and
he says i don't know what you guys are
making this was right at the beginning
you said but
you guys look like you're having a lot
of fun
and i remember that and i was like
that's what i really like doing now i
like doing the interviews i like doing
the skits i like editing the videos i
like you know and and and so i just was
like let me
i have some money in the bank let me
play around with that because that seems
really insane that you could ever make a
living doing it but boy that's a lot of
fun and i and and the first day i did it
it was called the jaffe stream um
[Music]
you know it was probably the first or
the first week i forget when it was but
it was that
initial period
my son was playing baseball
and i just done a show where a furry
called in and i had never spoken to a
furry i knew them as a joke like oh
you're a furry huh
and i was like
i actually got to talk to someone who
self-identified as a furry and we had a
really nice conversation i was like
i told my
ex because we went and saw my son play
baseball it's like
i said it was amazing i'm like i talked
to this guy i don't know where he was
somewhere in the world and we had an
audience and we got to sort of talk
about things that i never would have
thought to ask before
and it was so addictive and it was so
fun um
[Music]
that
and that along with the fact that it was
immediate
like i can when i hang out with you guys
and i see my kids and i figure out my
plan for those today if i have an idea
for a video right i can make it and it's
up within a couple of hours or it's up
within a week if you have an idea for a
video game
five years maybe five years you'll see
it well you'll see it before in focus
test but it's just
i don't have i don't have the patience
for that anymore so i love the immediacy
of this i love the honesty of this
um
this feels right to me right i don't
know
if i'll ever be able to make a real go
of it like i did with video games at a
business level right but
i you know
i i can work you know i'm not an idiot i
mean i have to worry about that at some
point but
i can't worry about that right now
because right now i just know that this
feels
correct and everything else feels wrong
and i've had opportunity to get back
in the business
of a bag
well they they they said hey let's have
a call about a bag about a bag yeah it
wasn't it wasn't a done deal or anywhere
close the minute i heard it was tencent
i said give me a couple days to think
about it i wrote the guy back who was an
american executive for tencent and i
said man i i don't mean to be a jerk i
really do appreciate it but hey i'm
doing this show and i want to see where
that goes and also i just can't square
the china thing um
but um
yeah so anyway that's that that was how
i got to this no don't no doubt no look
very very impressive and i like what you
said in reference to kind of like your
gut and what you feel you know what i'm
saying and you have to gravitate towards
that into good good at it what i was
going to say
drafty like you are
having some success on youtube like we
always say like
the most successful type of person that
that that has a lot of talent is people
that can do stuff by themselves
and you do that in tenfold because it's
hard to do stuff by yourself there's no
one to bounce back and forth it's all on
you for the show and you know there's
not a lot of people it's like that's the
skill anyone can get but a lot of people
don't want to learn that when they can
just get one of their friends oh you
mean in terms of the conversation yeah
that's fair i mean
it's much easier to have talks like this
because yes you know and i don't mean
it's easy like what you guys do is easy
but in the sense that every time i go on
a show like this there are these
it's like when you're a kid and you go
bowling and the the the guidelines come
up the little bowling lane things to
keep the ball from going in the gutter
um when it's just me
yeah stuff can happen
and on one hand that's fun but i have
had my my challenge has been
uh i talked to you guys at the beginning
of this i struggle with the um's yeah
you know
and well yeah but the reason i say it is
because it's like you know usually
people like don't read the comments
don't read the comments and i'm like i
don't care about the comments because if
it's something that affects me it means
that's actually important to me maybe
the guy or the girl was rude right but
if that stuck in my psyche i'm like what
do i have to learn about that because
he's saying something
that's getting to me whereas if someone
said jaffe you know
you know every time you you know
eat a lollipop you know one of my
ancestors goes to hell i'm like okay
whatever you know there's no basis of
anything yeah but but so
you know sometimes people will hit me on
the comments and go oh dude the um's are
killing me and i'm just like oh yeah you
got it i know you know um but people
don't realize how hard that that is to
break like it's hard crazy
and then when you're doing it by
yourself yes you have to kind of
and i love the show because the energy
we have but i'm i always listen back to
it when i'm driving
i have to remember
that 95 of the audience is listening
after the fact right and
what's fun for the audience
live right isn't necessarily what's fun
for the person listening when they're
driving or in the the subway and the the
the moment that it really hit home is i
took my uh my daughter to see wwe
smackdown live here in san diego and i'd
never seen a live
wrastlin match and i'd watched it on the
tv and i really enjoyed it but it's kind
of like going to a live football game
there are no announcers there's no way
to help you figure out what's going on
it doesn't exist for the people in the
arena they're there for you know the
drama yeah but it's really made for
people at home and when i realized
they're they're two different products
going to an arena show for
wrestling and watching it on usa or
peacock or whatever
it's not the same product and so i
really have started to try to learn
to walk that line because that energy
from the live audience
makes the show better absolutely but it
can also go off the wheels yeah the
rails very quickly
not because things go bad but because
someone's like dude i tuned in to hear
you talk about ubisoft and now you've
spent 20 minutes talking about this guy
who thinks he's seen the smallest penis
ever in the world and
i'm interested in that because i'm like
the smallest penis i think i've seen the
smaller ones
you know i don't have the smaller i've
seen this
he went left right right so it's a very
uh and i think i'm getting better at it
but it's a very hard
you know bucking bronco to step on
it's fun it's fun well i'd like to give
a shout out to you for your integrity as
far as you know the activism stuff he
was like yo i'm not going to mess with
that stuff until well
okay i appreciate that but i always have
to preface it by saying
my integrity is only as strong as my
bank account yeah no no no and
uh came your situation came came your
way and again you know you stood on your
square because of whatever you felt in
that situation right and you couldn't
you can square that uh and not all money
is good enough right that's right so
trust because you know hey take this but
anybody would take any type of money if
they needed it
not true well you're it's not every well
it is true but it's not it's everybody
has a line where it's different and
everybody wants to think
that into the day they would not be like
they can offer you uh 20
you know i gotta eat and it's twenty
dollars but this stipulation is in that
twenty dollars
exactly but but when i'm saying
that's true but i think when you have a
family i think it becomes very very
different and i think when you're when
you're like like i said that john q
movie with denzel washington
when it's like
look i'm not a bad guy
my kid is going to die i don't care what
i have to do yes right there are you
know and so i just think just like i was
saying i think it's important at the
beginning of the show we were talking
about ambition and drive in a career
yeah
that is a result of things that have
already been baked a long time ago in
your psyche um it's not something you
just go i want that right you are who
you are and you can change it but
who you are in the meantime the choices
you make are based on who you are at the
moment right and so similarly with money
and with being able to have morals it's
pathetic that it is a privilege
to to be able to be morally upstanding
you know but i can that i can say
no thank you tencent
that i can say
i'm gonna do exactly what i want it's
like yeah it's a nice
drama piece or it's a nice story
narrative
but a lot of it has to do with the fact
that i'm not going to go hungry and my
kids aren't going to go hungry if i if i
you know tell him to [ __ ] off
but i'd like to think my my line is
really far away but you're never going
to notice if you were like uh four
months behind in mortgage lights getting
ready to get cut off and stuff like that
intense and be like hey man i was
thinking about
all right
10 cent i thought you said 50 cent i
hate that guy's music
so people in the chat uh i think you're
about to do it but they they want the
real yeah i thought about the chat i
wanted to because plus i want to sneak
kick in for this uh final time before he
goes
so last question that we do for again
first of all tremendous journey got to
give you your props on that i love
hearing these stories you know truly
inspirational and to help people
understand how the business was and and
works on a lot of levels so that's cool
and your drive tremendous i wanted to
get one okay but we'll get you back
because i definitely want to get more
into arcade stuff we can get enough game
and stuff but the question we have to
ask every guest in the realm i need lord
jaffe's top five video games or
franchises of all time
okay well first i i need clarification
because i always struggle with these
questions are you talking about what i
think are
the best as of 2022 or are you talking
about the ones that are personal to you
okay um
that's it's an impossible question um
for right now this could this could
fluctuate
this could change at any time but
yeah i know that you're kind of like
dude it's a simple question it's really
not fun
but okay i'll i i would say uh in no
particular order okay i would say eldon
ring hearthstone
um
[Music]
deus ex
and maybe
resident evil 7 vr playing through vr
and video contingency likes that but i
think he's had first of a couple
yeah but but i would say though that if
you're going to things that are more you
know uh foundational building okay you
know atari's adventure 2600 or
miss pac-man and gallagher
and um
uh
mario kart battle mode uh from the snazz
and flashback from this last
but that's what i'm saying it's like
there's there's like probably 20
categories of favorites based on what
you're looking for and it's i don't know
why i just i struggle with those
questions but people on my stream will
always go jeffy here's 10 bucks what's
your favorite video game i'm like dude
yeah because
it's more like if you're on a stranded
on the desert island you can only talk
oh hearthstone
okay
yeah that's that's that's basically it
so that's the mentality of mine if you
can only play these five games for the
rest of your life okay that's very
different questions yeah i would i i i
would change transformed into that yeah
i would say okay that's i would say
hearthstone i would say roblox um
because hey i can play with my kids but
also because it's never-ending variety
of games they're a lot of them are crap
but um
i would say um
[Music]
elden ring
uh
because it's a great escape um
wordle
well because every day it's something to
look for if you're in a desert island
it's like a world time the world's out
that's something to do
um
and then um
whatever game uh
that uh uh what is her name dizzy kitty
on twitch plays every night oh it's so
hot
connection i have to a woman on the
desert island
i'm like these are ontario motives but i
respect it
and it turns out there's like a resort
on a hill they've been watching there's
a lot of
favorite console of all time and why
um i mean again okay um
[Music]
king's got to take the question i'm so
sorry but your your question is too
impossible
like love you love too much that's what
it is
are you asking about are you yeah are
you asking about which one has
the you know the atari has the nostalgia
win okay right okay
but but i don't want to play it for more
than five minutes
the the super nintendo
probably is battling i mean the best
game console of all time is the pc
that's just the absolute i think i think
the best way to do this is what is the
console that you have the most memories
of like wow
he said sorry he said
yeah anything that you were yeah but
that hard five minutes though
yeah yeah pitbull harry is a hard
pitfall harry for 10 minutes right or
you know load runner
right we out of here yeah
come over to my house i got this new
sports game what do you do you shake the
stick
[Laughter]
i respect so nostalgia would be 2600 and
then you would say
snes or pc you said pc well sne is the
super nintendo or what we called it i i
came to know what is the snap
sony when we were testing games for it i
i think the variety and the creativity
was really big then so i would say you
know
if you're talking console i would say
it's got to be between the super
nintendo the 3ds and the playstation 2.
um
but i think for me if you really were to
say you can have a desert island yeah
thing to play games on
you know people got people got so many
so just ah people they got so mad at me
because i was talking and i i tweeted i
said you know people were talking about
the delays and start feeling all that
good
and i was just like you know and i made
sure to preface it and say hey when you
can afford it because it's expensive i
get it
we you know my parents had to save up
like crazy and then they could only
afford to display apple 2e that was on
display in the window you know it was
computer's not cheap
but
compu playing games on a computer if you
love games not if you're a console
fanboy or whatever if you love
games
the sheer volume
and the sheer variety
um is is just
i i would say at this point if you want
to be a designer of games and you're not
playing on pc or you're not saving up
for a pc or you're not going to a place
that has a pc to experience
steam and it's io literally four days
ago uh the usc game expo usc is where i
went to school
but it's been uh uh you know uh named
like the number one school for video
game theory and design production
uh in the world
um they literally had their expo you can
go online now only on your pc
see like 40 games these students made
most of them are [ __ ]
um but there's a couple of them that
you're like these guys or girls could be
the next you know genova chins and that
game companies right well you can
download those and play them mostly all
of them on your pc i get that's not
uncharted 5. right but if you're into
design if you're into the medium
graphics is only a part of it so if
you're if you're serious about design
you either need to be on a pc or be
figuring out how you can get on a pc
because that's where the games are no
doubt tremendous history tremendous top
five
love the experience man absolute legend
in the realm he's still hanging out with
us we got more to talk about um what i
want to do king if you don't mind just
keep looking at my ears
i just want to get right into that one
topic which you can go for yeah so let's
just
solve we'll skip the poll and then we'll
do the super chat after this topic
because we gotta get king and jeffrey
all right so we can get this one one
time yeah you can get this one
all right cool
no doubt falls we got you games talk
loud we got you king is coming but we
the realm demanded all of them be
present for this topic so look let's
just get straight to it um yeah so may
12th it looks like bethesda put out the
tweet that rocked the industry right now
and an update on red fall and star field
we've made the decision to delay the
launches of redfield and start red fall
in star field to the first half of 2023
the teams of arcane austin and bethesda
game studios have incredible ambitions
for their games and we want to ensure
that you receive the best most polished
versions of them we want to thank
everyone for their excitement for red
fall and starfield that energy is a huge
part of what inspires us every day and
thanks drives our own excitement for
what we are creating we can't wait to
share our first deep dive into the
gameplay for both red fall and starfield
soon thank you for your support so this
definitely broke the internet a big
surprise and then phil
king his full name dominus maximus
aurelia spencer
put out the tweet that definitely also
reverberated um right after it which was
these decisions are hard on teams making
the games and our fans while i fully
support giving teams time to release
these great games when they are ready we
hear the feedback delivering quality and
consistency is expected we will continue
to work to better meet these those
expectations so this had a lot of people
in a frenzy uh lord jaffe definitely had
some comments here and and and very
strong opinions about this let's start
right with him now that the dust is
settled a little bit for 2022 as far as
xbox game studios output where do you
stand with this whole situation
well
okay i'm
okay
making games making games is incredibly
hard yes right making games now because
of the risk involved financially is
incredibly uh
you know uh it's very serious business
for people's careers and people's
wallets and things like that so i under
this isn't easy
uh throwing covet on top of it makes it
triply hard right okay so i i'm not i'm
not uh so my issue isn't that starfield
isn't coming out
on time
i'm looking forward to it i i
am very excited about the high concept
of skyrim in space i think that sounds
awesome
and and i love when you hear the guys
talk about
it
it's kind of in between hard sci-fi and
space opera i'm glad they're not just
going for this kind of you know very
serious science fiction arthur c clark
but it's there's some star wars in there
too and i'm like okay this sounds this
sounds great excuse me um
but so i don't care that it was delayed
if they delayed it for a year i
certainly don't care about red fall the
last thing i want is another co-op
you know i mean the trailer looks oh the
trailer powers of the vampires look
really cool the characters look like
they're trying really hard uh to be cool
and funny and just shut up um but the
the vampire mechanics look really cool
of course i'll try it right um but it's
it's not you know i'm kind of over you
know i did like very much evil dead the
other night but you know whatever so
but so the issue i had with it is not
those individual games the issue is
i am a very big believer in game pass um
not
xbox or sony it's not about that it's
it's about looking at what phil spencer
has promised and then what phil spencer
is i feel like i'm in that scene in a
pulp fiction
with uh with the with the watch that
came out of crystal oh
but but yeah so i mean what what i see
in game pass a lot of people disagree
with me and that's fine but i i see it
as a
uh ability to make the medium better
right i i'm very into i just love
everything in phil's vision i love
uh that he has
figured out a way to extract a crap ton
of money from microsoft to go out and
acquire these companies um which if they
can get their crap together
the cadence of
meaningfully big games
with the number of studios they have
would be anywhere from three to six a
year and that's not counting
the third party that's not counting the
indie and and i i'm not one of these
guys that poo poo's netflix or hbo match
or disney plus i love those
i love them and so if suddenly just like
you know i love that i can come home and
turn on netflix on a friday and there's
probably seven new things right you know
i love that so it's more disappointment
that you've got this guy
in phil spencer that
has managed to do so much right and the
way i always say it i'm not great at
analogies but it's like the man has
figured out a way to build
you know the back to the future delorean
but he doesn't have the plutonium you
know he keeps dropping the ball and
getting the plutonium to get the goddamn
thing to work right and it's like your
vision is great what you've built is
great but
you have consistently
dropped the ball when it comes to
getting software out which is a
management problem
and people came back at me this week and
we're like well that's matt boot and
it's not matt booby's problem
phil you know the buck ultimately stops
with whatever so you go from a hierarchy
standpoint well
i've i've worked in this industry in any
industry whether you're working in games
or baskin-robbins into the day
if you've got uh somebody who's serving
ice cream at baskin robbins and they
consistently
are friendly and wonderful but they keep
dropping the ice cream when they're
handing it to the customer
yeah that individual is a problem but
why is his boss for
five years let him keep working there
right right or why haven't they said
this guy is great at this but don't let
him do the ice cream right right so
ultimately yeah i mean if phil spencer
at this point and i know he has he's not
a [ __ ]
but if he hasn't been able to recognize
and then figure out how to pivot
the i mean this is a guy who
launched hardware
with no software right you talked about
this you talked about the series x
launched without yeah
s and x there's nothing not just halo
there was no first part of correct i
mean it's like when steve jobs launched
the lisa it's just like what do you do
with this thing you know i mean
obviously they had the backwards
compatibility and all this but it's like
you know um this is a guy who
delayed halo
which you how do you do how do you do
that it's your number one you know
what's fun you gotta do it you wanna go
well i'm not done i'm not done i'm done
you go forward
what i'm doing is i'm i'm i'm kind of
amber hurting this i'm painting you a
picture
i'm painting you a picture of chronic uh
uh behavior
it's not a one-off it's
it's the lack of software at all when
you launch your hardware it's your
delaying of halo and not being able to
read the road to realize this was not
going to be ready in 2021
it's halo coming out and then living
with six months of nothing and now the
anemic season two that they've just
dropped right when it makes zero sense
why it's taking that long to make maps
other than the fact that maybe their
code is such a uh spaghetti noodle bowl
of insanity that it's like dude it's a
nightmare to make a map in this engine i
don't know uh this the the uh the uh the
issues happening over at uh they're
getting better but the issues happening
over at undead labs right make state of
decay uh the initiative the initiative
which i'm
xbox fans will be like but that was what
it was supposed to be from the beginning
no it wasn't show me one
show me one piece of media that says
we're gonna hire all these big expensive
people
but ultimately the plan is for a bunch
of them to leave and give this game to
someone else to make this that was that
that spin there's a problem there
um
and then now you've got
bethesda i'm not saying phil spencer's
job you know
so do you attribute it to to be because
the acquisition was supposed to be that
they would be self-contained do you also
attribute that to him no yes
well in the sense that
i i don't think
i don't you know people are so coming at
me online i'm like i'm not saying phil
spencer is sitting there late at night
with a spreadsheet going
you know artist number four on the halo
team needs to work a little bit more on
bizarre level right uh to make the you
know that of course he's not doing that
matt booty's not doing that the head of
the studio is not doing that there are
people down the hierarchy that deal with
that right but ultimately
if you're phil spencer now here here's
what i would say if you're phil spencer
and
and you were counting on bethesda right
and you allowed yourself to build your
christmas plan right around that
uh confidence right
that expectation that it would be your
inability as an executive to go
that's probably not going to make it you
could you know
people chew hay could play something and
go
really
this is going to be ready and six this
is not gonna be ready in six months you
know and suddenly the wheels would start
turning the team that's why people are
like god awards like no the animator
says it's coming out the lead animator
may not know right but i guarantee you
there are people behind the scenes all
the time going is this still going to
make it mark it's going to make this it
didn't make it in 2021 when it was
supposed to come out right so so
it's less about it not coming out and
more about one more example of a very
important milestone
that
under phil's leadership
has been missed now if phil comes out in
june which i think he will
um or maybe even before and say i know
you're disappointed
we got you trust me you're gonna love
your christmas and what he comes out
with is
you know the only company i'm gonna make
a video about it later today the only
company i could find is is warner
brothers that they could possibly go to
right and say we we can't have
exclusives right now because of the
acquisition it's we really gotta you
know keep our nose dry um but
harry potter is gonna be game pass day
one yeah he'll still be on playstation
right but hogwarts is gonna be day one
game pass
gotham knights is day one game pass and
maybe one other thing and they're like
we
he won't say this but you know we've
written a check for over like 600
million dollars because we want you to
have an amazing christmas then i'd say
awesome right you got a back-up plan
that's what a good executive does right
um but there's no indication of that
um and maybe
let's put it this way if they were
having those conversations his message
wouldn't have necessarily said gotham
knights and harry potter because they
might want to save that till june yeah
but his message would have been
i know this is disappointing right but
don't worry there's great there's great
stuff to reassure the base to read the
show but there was nothing which means
if that comes
he's probably trying to do it now which
means one more example of you didn't see
this coming
i got one question before i give it a
kick because this is great i know you
got to go there's a great discussion
point my question is what about the
mindset that we we heard during the 2018
in the acquisition of all these studios
right yeah and one of the things that i
mean iop has had a lot of these studios
on
obsidian undead labs themselves um you
name it 343 and all these guys right so
my question is
part of the discussion piece was said
that's but made the acquisition and for
these guys compulsions guys like
attractive was that they were told hey
we're going to allow you to do you right
and it was almost like the budweiser
distillery thing like okay we make
really small little stew that makes this
craft beer and then here comes bulk wise
and it's like yeah do what you want with
the distillery and we're not gonna
micromanage now my question to you is do
you think there's an issue with the
conflict of micromanaging and kind of
hovering over studio where as a poll as
opposed to
microsoft with their reputation like hey
you know if you get acquired by
microsoft they go a medal you know the
older reputation you know like you know
if they come in you know the studio
culture is going to change do you think
maybe the problem might lie in that
where it's maybe do you think it's two
hands off approach and there should be a
cracking of the whip so to speak and
then comes the
culture
the thing that's important to know
though is is is just because the press
release tells you something
like everyone's taking that as gospel
and i guess for me the reason i don't is
i'm like you know again i worked in this
for 20 something years the press tells
you what the press wants you to know the
press is not no i get that part i get
that part i'm talking about hold on oh i
one second the only thing i'd cut you on
is that i get you at a press release i'm
with you there but
leave literally no people in the
building in a lot of these buildings and
it is explicitly because i've i wouldn't
believe it i was like they're going to
let you really do what you want to do
they really gonna let you not
micromanage you and and kind of put
their and they're like no god like this
is what it is we're allowed to to build
what we want and do what we want so
again do you think it's more of maybe
their two hands off no i i understand
your question i'm just saying that if
you're building that argument on
the
you have to first off extract the fact
because i see a lot of people saying
well no they said they were going to be
hands off it's like
you don't know what they're going to be
right right ea said they were going to
be hands off with bioware come on i mean
you know i'm saying they'll say one
thing to make the gamers feel
comfortable right that's their job to
make you want to buy their product so
that has to go out the window you don't
know what's true when it comes to what
the press says but um
when it comes to yeah i mean i obviously
heard the stories of the micromanagement
under the previous regime that was bad
right um
certainly if what people say is true and
if you read some of the stuff from
undead labs and the initiative
it sounds like there is a reoccurring
narrative of
they're very hands-off right and not
just with bethesda but with their own
team right yeah and so
i
uh if that is true
i think that is moronic
um i i i think that is and and it's like
also we're not we don't have crunch
that's moronic it's like you were
playing in the nfl guess what
sometimes if you want to win the super
bowl you got to take some steroids you
got to [ __ ] go
i mean i mean no i mean so so we so we
saying crunch then
so we say microsoft got to make them
crunch
they've got to do something now if
microsoft
they don't have to microsoft could say
we're going to keep throwing money at it
so they don't have to crunch that's fine
too
because if you don't crunch your costs
go up if your quality doesn't go down
right right but then the job from phil
is to make sure
while they're taking the extra long time
because they're not crunching is to have
something for his consumers
it's like you don't go to mcdonald's
it's like i know burger king has you
know the whopper
big mac's going to take two more weeks
i'm hungry now [ __ ]
yeah
right but but yeah so so the idea yes it
could be that it seems like that's part
of it but that again is a fill problem
it's like
you know
stops
but also because of and this one i mean
when i was at sony when we first became
playstation right we spent five years
canceling things left and right yep
things were green lit that there was no
gameplay
uh we signed developers that had no
[ __ ] id
um
that is learned right running product
development from shu from alan from
shannon from connie booth
a they're brilliant at their jobs and
they're good at their jobs in terms of
their they have that skill set but also
they've gone through boot camp which was
playstation one
and in playstation one we got to fail
because we had
metal gear solid we had crash bandicoot
we had spyro we had all these games
well yeah but we had all these games
that were
making they were feeding the fans
while first party was becoming what it
is today right well michael there's not
saying that they had all right so all
right to get to this let me get let me
just
i gotta i gotta run in this dude show
all right i i just wanna finish the
thought that jeff king
yeah yeah um
so it could be that microsoft has all
the resources all the marketing a
growing market share but what they don't
have though is they haven't
been through
enough of the storm to have emerged as
creative leaders who know how to produce
games
and those people are hirable
they're not curing cancer but they're
not saving the astronauts
sony those people were grown
yes go steal them
no but he stole a lot
not at that level not at that level he
hasn't all right so let's let's let's
look at that what it is right let's look
at it for
for the dog days all right because i'm
i'm that dark days dude that was over
there at xbox one and we already know
that uh he patrick hewned it and finger
rolled and messed us up right so all
right so they give phyllis this thing
that was supposed to die
it didn't die
because he went into pachinki with the
knife and he made sure he made it happen
so he's at the point right now where
he's about to get his chicken dinner
but
this thing called crunch this culture
that they had before where oh microsoft
gets their hands in it they're to meddle
in it and they're going to mess it up
that's not crunch that's different than
crunchy well meddling hey you got to get
this done crack down remember those
things well those are very different
things you're talking about microsoft
coming in and saying
we don't like this we want this change
this isn't good enough that might be
meddling that's different than saying
yeah yeah all right so
we already have the like the checklist
of games like scalebound didn't make it
because right microsoft won it's one
thing or whatever right and then you had
the crunch that didn't work with
crackdown and a crackdown actually comes
out and there's a broken game all the
stuff is done on the field
but all the stuff is older stuff
so now you hear all the stuff that
you're doing and that that that um how
can i say that you were uh
being um harassed about now you got all
these studios but you built the platform
that platform gives you uh flexibility
because now you have to bag like you
said they probably don't have no games
this year for the end of the year those
first party games that like star feel
and red for games that nobody knows
exactly what they are but they up in
arms over it which is awesome yeah we
know how you feel about that oh god i
gotta have this game that i've never
seen before that has no pedigree with me
that i'm so concerned about that they
said they need time to think all right
like you said they're able to throw some
money at the problem and put these first
party day one game i mean um
hopefully that's what happens yeah oh
hopefully but they've been doing it so
far right no
not at the yeah but not at the level
they need to
maybe
do
this year they have to because
this is probably going to be the last
christmas where i mean xbox is selling
great now because it's one of the few
things that you can find
to not
to trip up now so close to being able to
really change the conversation
would be
awful because they're so close now
there's two things they have to do they
got to get through this christmas i
think with something meaningful that is
makes people go into a store and say ah
that looks better than sony's box or
switch
and they need to bring on some managers
know what the hell they're doing when it
comes to product development all right
so would you say that
this year
they could potentially go this year how
come i don't get a kiss
[Laughter]
you say that this year they can
potentially because there's uh they're
selling high-end software i mean
high-end hardware and game passes being
you know successful and probably they're
probably going to announce the puck or
the stick it's going to be on people's
tvs without a console it's great i love
it i love it
but okay so you think that they can
actually do something in that vein as
far as throw more stuff inside game pass
to give the developers
more time on these games that if they do
come out broken right
there's no recovering from starfield
coming out messed up sure they're well
that's not true that's absolutely you
you think they could recover from a
broken stadium launch they recovered
from skyrim they were recovered from cd
projekt ram come on
gamers are obnoxiously full of [ __ ] yes
we are yes we are
you know there's a lot of hyperbolic
talk going around yeah you complain but
then you show up for you know but yeah
but then we have a cyberpunk situation
where yeah you have a game that clearly
did not meet expectation and should have
been delayed so so you rather than put
out a half finished no no no no no of
course not but that's the job it's a
balance it's like you're saying that
he's not balancing that job and he needs
well he if he shows up in june and says
we've got harry potter day one and we
we can't make call of duty exclusive but
we can make it day one xbox we can pay
activision for that because we know
we'll be getting the money back um
because it's our money you know once we
buy them um
but i mean imagine that but that's what
an executive does right it's like people
like he would he managed to get
microsoft to spend 60 billion it's like
well now he's got to get a little more
because if you walk in and again i don't
know a lot of people buy on digital now
but let's say you walk into best buy and
you're a parent or you're a college kid
whatever you're looking for a console
and yeah playstation 5
you know for the most part better
graphics definitely better first party
software in terms of the best of the
best in a certain genre which is they're
amazing no one does it better than sony
first party with the narrative based
single player games and all that
just
but if you walk into best buy and
they're like this is the sony right
proposition
and the xbox proposition oh call of duty
the new one modern warfare 2 that's day
one hogwarts oh my kid wants to play
that that's day one right gotham knights
oh in all these other games that's day
one and then here's what's coming
okay baby that is what
i mean that's right that makes it makes
it it makes the system more attractive
attractive
your job is not to ship starfield buggy
your job is to ship something right to
make your fans happy absolutely and i
agree king i'll let you go because yeah
um listen
i had a great time yeah this is
everything that i expected it to be and
i i i i'm so upset that i got to go but
what is better where else do you have to
be there
with me
it's his last show and he's the fans the
one if it wasn't for fun
so without my man fawns uh this wouldn't
be possible correct like i said it got
to be bittersweet i would love to sit
here but i know you're going to come
back yeah whenever you guys invite me
i'll be here i was just going to join
12. i'll definitely get you back here
do your thing and if we're still going
come back
i got to get addicted because he's been
quiet and i know he's been sitting on
that heart yeah
yeah can you guys hear me yeah we can
hear you get here we know you're hurting
right now you're suffering just to be
but what what you're feeling man what
the with the delay you know in the
statement
where's your mindset with uh red fall
and starfield delayed into 2023.
i feel like look
in the in the grand scheme of things i
don't think it's like a huge huge issue
because i don't think it's going to get
delayed enough to
really affect the bottom line but when
it comes to
2021
november 2022 my bad 2022
it it's just not a good look because
it's just like you know regardless
i'm
we lost you
yeah we
i'm 100 with jaffe on
look just because you guys might not
necessarily need starfield this holiday
consider you have nothing because you
know the competition unless god of war
sticks it there's not going to be a lot
over there either but it's like nintendo
is doing good but the thing is is like
you don't come up it's like i was
telling cognito it's like
microsoft here lately has been the king
of setting up the layout but not
actually getting the bucket
and it's just like look like
you can do good this
this is probably the last
holiday
where these it's it's it's going to be a
limit on how much concerts is out there
in the wild now look people could say
you know that's not fair to sony well
it's it's not but guess what microsoft
had the money to uh make it a little
advantage to themselves and it's just
like it's not it's not it's not a
sport but it's it's business they you
know sony had the money too right why
they didn't spend money accelerating
chips i don't know but anyway started
going yeah good point yeah so look like
this holiday
is going to be very crucial on making
sure they get as much sodas as they
possibly can
but i don't know how much they're
realistically going to make either so
maybe their mindsets like look starfield
needs a little bit more time to develop
and what's the point in putting out a
game
that might be broken and i do understand
where you're coming from jeffy where you
say they can recover because
historically we have seen games recover
over and over again but i do feel like
like cyberpunk put a giant spotlight on
those types
please please don't misunderstand i
don't care if starfield comes out if
they need more time right if god if god
was worried i was worried jeffrey you
sounded like he was cool with the broken
gate shipping
is pretty much saying the game can
recover if it was broken but you don't
want it he's just saying that
what i'm saying is the issue isn't
starfield not coming out the issue is
not having a backup plan
is having assumed starfield would come
out and not being able to read the
roadmap well enough to go this thing
coming out
i think the biggest issue jaffe
is like
last year they look they put a date
and it's just like not only did they put
a date they put a date in the trailer
right and
at the end of the day like you know
it's not just one or two things it's
multiple things it's the condition the
three four threes in it's the condition
that if that uh the initiative's in it's
the condition that you see every while
doesn't even know what they want to be
like like i do understand that now i
don't like i do feel like
there might be a magical problem but the
thing is is
what would it be well no no no no i'm
not i'm not disagreeing with you no i
know but i know but you're saying might
which means you have an option so what's
the option
what i was going is i don't know if it's
that or there's just so many studios and
maybe they need more help monitoring
them
that's management right well you get
what i'm saying i'm talking about the
current management and adding additional
man i know but if the current management
doesn't have the wherewithal to
recognize we don't have the resources to
deal with our massive number of studios
that's bad current management you're not
going to improve that by bringing more
people in to follow a bad manager
so
i agree with you but if if there's too
much work for
the amount of people realistically doing
it wouldn't you think it would be
more beneficial to help bring people to
help them
yeah but we're in triage mode
you're trying to sort of
you're you're sort of operating under an
assumption that
this isn't a chronic problem that has
been going on for many many years at
that company ultimately you can bring
more look if phil spencer at this point
or matt booty at this point can't
recognize that they don't have enough
people
to do their jobs
that's a that's a very bad reflection on
their ability to do their jobs all right
so so just just for clarity i just want
to ask in reference to
this specific because obviously it's but
that's the game studios it's to addict's
point 11 11 was kind of put out there by
todd howard at all interviews they said
this was uh outlined in ink or chalk or
whatever and you know at some point we
saw the marketing right we saw even the
the xbox but there's the showcase
marketing the you know the whole star
field kind of vibe right we've seen the
vidox right whether or not gameplay is
there or not is another issue but we've
seen almost like this cadence to almost
a rollout of like something that is
anticipated to launch so i say all that
to say this in a sense that now that
this has happened right
do you think and this is very bad do you
think that this is a situation that
happened last minute because prior to
this they felt it felt like this thing
was ready to go like when you give a
date a year and a half no they just
didn't no it wasn't right so so so now
the question becomes now let's just say
obviously we see the tweet we see you
know everyone in the building in in
bethesda whatever they showed whatever
and anticipation seems to be like it's
still coming and then there's a picture
of
in the theater yes in the theater with
todd and
pete and the crew you know you got to
wonder about that what was the pr behind
that because it's not like they didn't
know but that's the question like is it
a could it potentially be a situation
where
it was last minute like oh this is not
ready and
may and maybe just maybe
that todd approaches them right and say
look this is where we at we're not
trying to hit this right and now phil
has to die on his sword
for them not meeting the deliverable
do you think that is a potential because
it sure yeah okay but who cares
how many swords do you guys want to give
the man to die on the the thing is not
once his word is where jeffy jeffy is
right i know he's like it doesn't matter
yeah he's not doing that
right
it's 343 it's ever wild it's the
initiative it's launching without any
software for your brand new game console
i mean it's on and on and on and let me
ask you if you own stock and microsoft
wouldn't you be going
guys
what's going on
this is not normal right this does not
happen in video games this is not normal
well delays are no way delays are normal
come on not to this just wait hold on
i would not be here and this discussion
wouldn't be this uh
top of mind
if they just said oh starfield's delayed
oh yeah that sucks god of war is
probably going to be delayed
but starfire and red four i feel you on
that okay um it's not about that it's
about one more really big
plate that stopped spinning and fell to
the ground and get that
my counter to that and again i hate to
do what about ism and what the other
people are doing
but literally the two first-party
releases for sodium this year are
delayed games that came into 2022. so
it's happening it's happening on the
other side where i agree with would be
you meet in the middle sony also
i know i know i know this is where i
meet in the middle with you where i meet
in the middle with you is foresight to
say okay if these are not going to
launch right we got to have
contingencies right we gotta have either
some third party exclusive game that
that's gonna be ours or launching game
pass you know and you look at sony
they've got for spoken even though you
know it's kind of time exclusive
whatever there's other things in play
and that's where i meet in the middle
with you or all i'm saying is that when
delays happen
breath of the wild is supposed to be
supposed to be out a year two years ago
right so
it's just a continuous they have plenty
of other rise
i think that's the disconnect
that microsoft seems to want to invest
more into their first party and sony's
willing to do both
so
and i think that at this point
you know like he said uh i don't think
they can do like exclusivity stuff
because you know these games are
probably too close to being launched uh
on top of that you know they have the
the whole activision thing going on
but if you it how bad
is that marketing gonna be if you have
nothing to market no it's a devastating
blessing
i mean it's you know i mean again for
spoken i don't think it's gonna set the
world on fire right either i don't think
people are like i can't [ __ ] wait for
but it's still but it's still a game
it's still a 70
game that you can you know i mean you
know it it's very it's very easy that
could also be the next ghost wire tokyo
which is like some people like but it's
not going to you know um but but again
though again my issue is not
i don't even know why this is like i i
know phil spencer has this kind of cult
of personality and i don't really
understand why i'm like
because
saving but i believe i believe in his
vision i think it's great but he's a
human he's he he can drop the ball
and more importantly
you know there
you know there are things that we're
good at right and there are things that
we're not good at he just he's not good
at this that's just yes that's your
opinion that's what you feel like he's
excited
well there is no other option based on
the information that is given right i
would agree with the information we have
these are the assumptions they've given
us no choice to assume what you're
you're assuming perception's king right
everything is perception
perception it's do you have games for
your xbox right no that's not perception
you either have them well you don't
let's get let's get solving because i
know you've been patient and i'll go but
solve what's your favorite i have not
talked to you this whole week really
about this i am very curious in like two
weeks really yeah let's
agree with everything i said i'll let
you kiss me again
don't blow kisses to jeffy
no
i mean all right on on the on your
response itself david um i guess the
only thing
the only thing that again you're known
for saying things off the cuff and what
i mean by off the cuff is sometimes
whatever comes to mind comes out of your
mouth whatever but you're never
disingenuous so everything that you say
comes from the heart and it's something
that you truly believe in
i just
think that for me personally i'm an old
school guy you tell me i need therapy
and we have a discourse about it we have
a discourse about it i'll be honest i
don't like that yeah it doesn't bother
me like that that doesn't bother me but
i can see how it can bother other people
because it personalizes it that's the
only thing i understood what you meant
dave
i don't know i'm sorry did i personalize
the console war did i did i step over
the line but it's like if me and me you
get into it right right and i'll be like
yeah but that's why you need therapy
though
it takes it somewhere else
but it's a back and forth too like we
can respond to one another and we could
see the tone we've talked a number of
times about how twitter
it just you can't tell tone right you
can't tell intention
i wasn't on twitter it was a video oh it
was a video
a video so
it's one of those things where it is
left up to people to sort of kind of
interpret as they see fit and pull out
of it as they see fit and you've been a
victim of this a lot of times where they
just pull stuff out and and it happens
and not the country so i didn't be
brutally obsessed jeffy i didn't like
what they did to you
when you know we're gonna get into the
god of war you know the deal that's your
opinion but wait when you personalize it
and it is a per you know it and i know
you didn't go to that extreme i know you
ain't go there but that's why you're
talking about the therapy thing yeah i
like it okay but what you guys have to
understand is i i i don't there's
nothing about therapy that i find
shameful no i am on antidepressants with
zoloft i am on adhd medicine i have been
in and out of therapy uh
since i was 20 years old i'm not in it
all the time but you know
and i think everyone needs therapy in
terms of like a check-in you know even
if you think you're the most healthy
person in the world
once or twice a year
check in with a mental health uh advisor
who's uh objective because you know the
world would be a better place if we got
out of our own heads and actually
was able to sort of you know be the
is-ness of the moment you know
um so i wasn't insulting him what i was
trying to point out was this is an
achilles heel this is a blind spot that
i think is personal with the guy i think
this is a guy
well i think it's personal in the sense
why can't you recognize this blind spot
you have so much you have so much to
offer you are so close
to to disrupting the game in a great way
in my opinion i've all people accuse me
being a chill for game pass yeah that's
how much i might believe in game pass um
but i'm like dude
why can't you recognize this like
everybody
i i just feel like i i'm
the way it sounded like is because you
were uh you know saying you think it
might be phil spencer's personal ego
that puts him down this road yeah the
way it sounded like to me you would say
maybe you need to have that looked at
like
some people that's exactly what i meant
like big because i don't know if phil
spencer i don't know what's going behind
but but that's what it seemed like to me
when i was looking on twitter it seemed
like people were trying to say that you
were seeing seemed like phil spencer
like needed mental health no i
understood i understood this
i understood this over a point my thing
is again not just we just agree to
disagree on that part but right
my thing is i think your point would
have resonated more if that one word
wasn't there or because i feel that it
was your overall point of words
because i think it it sits above this
conversation about xbox and it's more
to the point of your podcast my podcast
social media
you when you do this as frequently as we
do this you have to make a conscious
choice to say
i'm either going to
make an effort
to communicate to people
who are not
listening and not really paying
attention i get that and the more effort
you make chances are the more successful
in numbers you're going to be
because it's just you know people are
busy when they're listening to a podcast
and they go off half [ __ ] because they
got their own lives and all that
i'm
placing my bet on the fact that i'll
never be as popular as you guys i'll
never be as popular as colin moriarty's
show no no no no no it is about building
your stuff though you want to make some
respect right
no that's not my point i'm not i'm not
i'm not i'm not being self-deprecating
what i'm saying is there are two routes
you can take you can take the route of
you know three you can go so vanilla
that you become kind of funny which is a
problem shout out to california
i like greg miller a great deal but
since they've lost colin that
group has become very milk toast it's
not it's not good
of course and that's what they want to
do and that's great um and you can be
more middle of the road that's like look
we're going to be honest but we we're
going to take into account that some of
you guys are busy some of you guys have
preconceived notions we have to be a
little bit more ginger with how we
express our views
my bet is on
i will have a smaller audience
but they'll be more passionate because
they know
you getting that 100 when i speak you're
getting a genuine response and beyond
that
it's not mean-spirited right you know i
i don't like anyone who knows me i talk
about my therapy i talk about my mental
health
i don't think saying hey your ego
is getting into i think you're gonna use
ego you'd have been good bro yeah i
think you're gonna say no i think you've
been living that dad you'd have been
good you would have gotten no but i mean
it's it's you and how you forget
yourself
yeah i'm okay if you don't
the thing i i think
especially with men therapy is perceived
in a lot of ways and necessarily that's
not my problem
no i i'm not saying it's your problem
but i'm saying that the way society
perceives it yeah
i get it and if if my goal
was to
not
say things that confuse people because i
want to i really want more people to
really get
what i'm saying i know how to sand off
the rough edges i understand
communication what i'm saying is my joy
of what i'm doing is
i know i'm bringing an honest
conversation to people i'm not going to
water it down it doesn't mean it's
better it means that i don't want to
take the energy to take into account
you're very valid right communication
advice which is you're right
but i'm saying i don't care if i have to
do that this becomes less interesting
you're doing you you're doing it and
we've got i want to get back on point
with solve with his thoughts on this
whole thing
as far as this delay man so
all this other stuff aside right down to
the delays i don't
see me generally
i think a lot of it and this is an
industry-wide thing
i think it's more like just optics and
how you choose to speak about your games
that kind of puts you in this position
i'm at i'm at the point that i i
understand marketing cycles i understand
pre-order numbers and that stuff that
matters
but as we move more and more into kind
of this all digital future where quite
honestly like the pre-order doesn't
matter as much unless you have a
physical thing in store
it doesn't make any sense to me to keep
attaching dates to games
so damn early and i don't mean i mean
this was ridiculous talking about a year
out right but when you when you do see
that you're like they're very confident
they're going to be able to hit this
and so for me a lot of it a lot of this
can be avoided if you just don't attach
a date to it so yeah
yeah it's just because they keep they
keep stepping on this rake when you when
you go back to the launch of the xbox
the series x and the s
there were boxes already printed with
the halo in a bag
all of this this taco bell co-marketing
stuff that they have yeah i have the box
right over there that has a master chief
on it yeah
so i went in on them for that too yeah
it is it doesn't make it's a rake that i
i personally think that where gaming is
going now they don't need to step on
anymore and just if you don't put a date
on it it's difficult to be disappointed
when they finally say when they because
they're going to tell you when
when when the game is ready to come out
you know they'll be able to know three
months out two months out maybe you know
it's just one of those things where i
don't understand this and they keep they
keep creating a disappointment in my
mind that doesn't need to continue to
happen and this is world
well it's industry-wide but i would say
xbox could suffer more from it because
with sony
you have to have the hardware so you you
know i get they put a date on it because
they want people to buy their hardware
um with microsoft it's like if i can
play it on the stick or i can play it on
my pc or i can play on my xbox one the
old xbox
okay it's not going to make it i'll just
i'll cancel game pass until it comes out
like i mean that's they're actually more
vulnerable to this than no it's a good
one it's a good point because at the end
of the day the vision is game pass right
the vision is getting into this service
and having that cadence that you're
gonna have these first party titles
available and when you have two major
titles that are expected this year not
hit that service then there's going to
be repercussions because like you said
it's almost like a sunk cost because now
you have to pay money to potentially
facilitate what's missing right and then
on top of that you know you have to
convince people you know that to stay in
the service because your goal is to go
to that vision but sorry i keep
interrupting you continue okay that's
the thing if they had said nothing we
wouldn't be having this conversation
it's like starfield's not coming this
year well yeah but you'd be having a
different conversation which is what's
coming this year what's coming this year
right and
again because game pass i think to
jaffy's point
has already started to change the game
this idea of
needing to have
this big
aaa
experience that's associated with your
platform
is less important to me on the xbox side
um
then on the playstation side the
playstation sort of lives and dies by
that sort of thing
um they've never been really big on on
releasing big aaa games towards the end
of the years usually earlier in the year
if god of war comes this year it's going
to be late in the year
um
so i for me it's just one of those
things like
delays are so ingrained into what games
are now this is not back in the days
when you released the game and that was
it it was on the cartridge and if it was
broken it was broken if it was great it
was great there were no patches and in
this world where everything seems to be
so much more fluid now
it just kind of feels like
this is something to be expected and i
don't disagree with when you look at the
track record of things everything that's
happened from the xbox one generation to
now you know the crackdown taking
forever and still coming out and not
being a great game the multiple
developers that were on that that that
that game um the stuff that happened
with you know fable legends all of that
stuff and scale bound all of that stuff
to jaffrey's point does seem to we've
talked about it ad nauseum here it
points to to issues along the pipeline
that are that need to be rectified right
i just i don't know it just feels like
everything is delayed now and you would
save yourself this scrutiny if you just
shut up about it until the game was
ready to come out because again then you
have conversations about people having
perceptions about uh
the the studio culture and all this
other stuff that starts coming up as a
result of this right what's wrong with
them that this is not able to come out
and for me it's just it's unnecessary
scrutiny
um basically you say they're doing it to
themselves putting themselves in this
i'm just of the mind that that's where
we are in gaming now as these games are
becoming more and more expensive to make
their body i can i can tell you
firsthand
that when someone delays a title i mean
everything's on the table it's like if
we do this this is the hit we take if we
don't do this that we take so it could
be that those release dates that i agree
with you are are becoming more
problematic
marketing could still be in there saying
we get it but the value that we get out
of telling somebody it's coming this day
even if we move it the damage we take
moving it is nowhere near the value we
take
you know announcing it but i don't know
what that value is they would say right
maybe it's more hardware sold i have no
idea
and that's the thing because when you
look at the value proposition when you
think about how many people are
purchasing games digitally now where you
know to me honestly if you purchase your
games digitally there's no reason to
purchase that game until maybe a day or
two before it comes out just so you have
it downloaded already right oh yeah pre
yeah preloading and pre-ordering is
stupid beyond that you know so i don't
understand that part of the marketing
cycle if there's a physical thing you're
selling a collector's edition or
something like that i kind of get that
but that is only for the hardcore really
it's not when you talk about the masses
that doesn't matter to the masses as
much so for me it just i don't know it's
it's just a rake that i think doesn't
need to be stepped on and it happens
industry-wide
and
it disappoints people all across the
board and we have these conversations
and for me you know i i want a good game
right so and and i do agree that when it
comes to a star field a star field
ideally they want that game to come out
and to be the antithesis of what we
expect of a bgs game which is right not
buggy
all of these other things and you know
if they need another year to get it
there because i think it's going to be a
year it's a year
for a flat out it's a year and i think
the same for for um
for what you're going to call it for uh
the banana red fall
red falls like
i don't think anybody cares about red
falls
i think
you think about red fall i'm not in my
mind i don't know what that is yet but
when i look at arcane i'm like okay if
you're applying like
uh sort of immersive sim type gameplay
to something that's co-op and something
that's pve versus you know pvp sort of
stuff that's interesting to me but it's
interesting to me if you describe it
that way but what they've shown so far
just looks like it's you know back for
blood
for blood or trying to be kind of like a
destiny like or something like that yeah
rgt podcast in the building playstation
nation what's going on sir i didn't know
if you guys even saw that guy he just
appeared
is that just me seeing
anything that's how people come through
the back door
let's go to a big club what's going on
man i got that vip access you got that
vip
coming through the back how you doing
jeffy good to finally meet you you as
well hey sob man i'm glad you brought
that up though you know it feels like we
always have this conversation going into
an xbox event right like every time like
whether it be a month away from the show
a few weeks away from the show there's
an announcement
or something that just is said on on an
executive's part that takes the wind
out the show type of thing you know the
biggest thing about this showcase and
this is not for the community doing this
right this microsoft one is they said
literally the biggest thing we're going
to get out of this showcase is starfield
when it made sense logically just the
way to the event have the game be shown
and then at the end it says it's coming
next year sony does this on a numerous
times what's the point of a tweet
honestly i i kind of don't agree with
you yeah
i just think
because whatever positive comes out of
what you see at that and this is just
gamers
being fickle being being petty being
childish you're going to see something
great and you're going to see that
changing date at the end and all the
great stuff is going to go out the
window and the conversation is going to
be dominated by oh they lied to us all
this and it's just again i'm not saying
that's us necessarily we'll have that
conversation
but it's just
perception becomes reality twitter's not
a real place
the the the stuff that's the stuff that
is that's gonna bring the most clicks is
what's gonna rise to the top and
obviously them coming out after giving
you a date 11 11 20 uh 22 and all of a
sudden just changing it slightly at the
end of the trailer
it's not going to bode well for them
listen to this though okay okay glad you
said that but i got you at it if you
look at the situation now right even
with them announcing this going into
this saying that it's still delayed does
that even change situation as it is it's
still kind of the same conversation
regardless yeah it's true you're being
transparent which is the the big thing
to take away from this microsoft is very
transparent so he's not transparent as
much with the community but
sometimes though on some real i would
prefer some stuff you keep to yourself
okay in times like this
especially when you know you have you
don't have anything pretty much if red
it would have been different if red fall
probably would have dropped this year
right at least you ended the year with
something you had a game right now
you're going into next year and two of
the biggest games we've been talking
about from xbox guess what yeah next
year yeah and this makes people question
sony as well is sony going to do
anything for this year are we going to
get that god award to uh ragnarok i mean
i think we are in june right all these
next topic we'll get to it
that's the thing but i i don't i don't
you know it's a lot of stuff but
back when the xbox thing it's just like
i don't know man it's always that weird
announcement that a weird team that just
messes with the shows another thing that
kind of got me about sort of the the
tone of a lot of the responses to this
has been like they have nothing and we
always get surprises right i don't
believe in my heart they have nothing
right it may not what surprises did we
get
no no in the past like well before the
horizon five
it wasn't announced until very late
um so things like stuff like rare replay
like little titles like that and stuff
like that well basically when people say
nothing is the replacement of a triple a
no no it's not an old starfield it's
where people are saying that some of the
conversation like i said it becomes
hyperbolic and it's like they have
nothing they have they haven't announced
anything but i mean
good at it the thing is is
regardless what they announced next
month
there's nothing that's going to take the
place of something like star cream oh i
don't know i don't agree with that oh
if they say day one call of duty for
free on xbox oh yeah if they say
hogwarts day one for free on xbox
they're not saying
mlb is a sony game but it's still on
game pass right so um and i don't know
if they're going to do that but they
better [ __ ] do so just do something
um we're getting into the third hour i
can't
yeah i mean i think if they do something
like that then i mean more frankly more
people are interested in terms of
a big audience and call of duty and
hogwarts anyway so if you're like oh you
mean that's day one that's quote free
which is psychologically what it feels
like
that's better than start field
age jeff yeah
you know next year we got spiderman too
that's going to be a big seller for the
playstation itself oh yeah um what's
your take on microsoft not really
playing i had this conversation with
these guys multiple times about this but
what's your what's your thoughts about
microsoft really avoiding
the superhero esque um
i guess character for like mascot for
microsoft
i mean
where are they going to go dc um i don't
think dc would really matter they can
there's a lot of characters you can go
with a marvel route you can get someone
like punisher to fit your console you
can go with you know i mean i love
superheroes so i think that would be
great to see um i would love to see
uh
you know uh i know people say the
collective and i agree with that but i
would love to see double fine
get a character like squirrel girl or
even doctor strange and you know get
maybe get some help with their
platforming because it's not very good
but their imagination is almost second
to none when it comes to things i mean
they could doctor strange the crap out
of dr strange it would be amazing but i
can tell you firsthand that spider-man
at sony was not an easy sell there were
many people for a very long time saying
that's a dumb idea
i mean and i would i'm a huge spidey fan
so i'm like are you sure
but i was stunned when i heard that when
people told me that there were a lot of
executives that were like they didn't
see it so
but i'd like you know i don't i don't
think they need it but i'd love to see
it yeah i mean like you know a lot of
people think they don't need it but i
think it's just it doesn't help the
console when you're kind of out of the
conversation
on one side right and one side is known
for having so many options like you
right with the storytelling games the
action adventure the shooters the horror
games now they have a dedicated
developer making you those um crazy
over-the-top you know um comic book
superhero games i think it would be
awesome for them to get the rights to
like batman superman world's finest and
then basically never ship it because
they don't seem to know how to ship
games i think that was
fantastic
because we go along with this one
i think at the end of the day when it
comes to star field when it comes to red
fall i think it's just the games it's
like look like
you could delay the games
but when these games come out they got a
hit
and
you got to show us consistently more
games obviously the pandemic's been a
factor and i'm sure it's delayed a lot
of internal stuff six months to a year
just naturally but it's just like when
these games start getting out they gotta
stop putting dates that's the biggest
thing they they gotta stop putting dates
and you know microsoft needs to do a
better job at managing some of these
internal studios to hit these dates
because if they're if they're not going
to hit the day that they supposed to
they need to say
we're not going to put a date on there
like it's like i said like they put the
date in the starfield trailer yeah
and people are just disappointed because
it's like look i know a lot of people
have like multiple consoles a lot of
people but there's a lot of people that
primarily play on stuff you got the
bethesda fans that was excited for star
field you got the xbox fans i was
excited for star field then it's just
like when you see
if you only have an xbox and you see
horizon being played on the other side
of the lake and you see uh the kirby
game be played
i get mine in november and then you get
you wake up to oh i don't get mine in
november so it's just people are upset
rightfully justice i do think that the
criticism is valid uh you know and it's
not it's like it's like jeffy said it's
like we've said multiple times there's
just too many incidences where something
is going wrong and i don't know if
that's a connection between the head of
the studios and above the head of the
studio or that's a connection where the
studios aren't doing what they're
supposed to and the management above
them aren't setting things straight
right well that's as far as that goes
how long do you think star field will
take you to finish
i'm just saying think about that i mean
all this
nonsense over you know
what's my game it's like think about the
state that we're in where
one game
like that's how long it's taking to make
these things that's how how important a
single game is i mean it's it's that is
not sustainable i mean the sooner the
sooner we can leave consoles behind and
get it pumped get it pumped into the tv
um i know not everybody can stream yet
like that but it's it's it's a
ridiculous concept that you get one big
game to look forward to on your console
and
you'll finish it in a week or two and
then what then what what i mean
white years for these games especially
me where i finish them well i i do a
little bit too much and finish them but
it's just like you know people just
excited like the hype
it looked like sure some people
shouldn't have hyped a game like king
says that has no gameplay or anything
like that but it's just like at the same
time people i can't have no right
telling me what to be hyped about so
it's just like you're like they do have
a right go ahead sorry
i it's just i enjoyed starfield i want
to play it when it comes out and
whenever i'm assuming like the beginning
of next year at some point like march or
april i don't know but it's just like
you know
it takes the whole year of 2022
and even though that there's other stuff
you could play if you have other
platforms when you look at xbox as a
just just a platform
it it looks bad like this is probably
the worst year i've seen for them
this is up this is up there
you know
kind of like in the top five
bad moments for them i'll be brutally
honest but this is the thing cog right
right just last year and i know a lot of
those games were the result of delays
right well last year
we had psychonauts two weeks ago oh it's
phenomenal we got five
right this is a great literally we're
talking about less than six months ago
and and and now the conversation for
some people is very doom and gloom right
i think i think what it is solved is
it would have been different if like one
game got delayed or
two there's nothing this year from the
first one
right now obviously june's gonna happen
they're probably gonna maybe we'll get a
forza game this year uh hopefully uh
maybe we'll get like some smaller games
like maybe a gears remake maybe but it's
just like first off it's kind of
interesting they chose before this
before they show whatever they're going
to show next month because if they would
have showed next month and then delayed
it like a month after that may we would
have more games okay wait at least we
have something to play but they delayed
it before we even know what's coming out
this year so now it's looking like
there's nothing to play let me jump in
because i'll be patient
um look i i get what everyone's saying
and this is a devastating blow this is a
devastating blow i'm not gonna sugarcoat
it i'm not gonna dance around it you
know at the end of the day i do feel
delay delaying the game is the right
call for the health of the game i'm
always going to stand on that one right
i just feel that especially on
bethesda's history from an engine
standpoint from what we know you know
that i always want them to have the most
time me personally i'm selfish i love
sci-fi i love space you know if you're
giving me the idea of elder scrolls in
space i'm in you know what i'm saying so
this was my highly anticipated and i'm
not an elder ring guy so for me this was
my highly anticipated title this bloke
crushed me this crushed me i was like
damn i really had this in my mind now
rev4 i'm kind of i don't know what it is
but
i think where it really hit it's the
double combo of two aaa first party
games at in one year and then it's like
okay well what's the contingency like
because it feels down your left bearing
and then i think
the other thing is just that
but i gotta be honest like like solve
like morale is at a low
because the reason why starfield
specifically is so significant it
represented the new xbox to me it
represented okay this is the new
first party this is not i hate to say it
halo gears 4 is a big mac large fries
are the shake that we used to get that
are great games don't get me wrong
they're great but it's like okay
this starfield symbolically represented
the new generation it was the beginning
of right and then you got the fall and
then the hope was big cloud that come
next year whether it be a vowel
hellblade 2. you know what i'm saying
like these are these new ips because i
speak to sony fans right shout out to
blink like we spoke i spoke i put it out
there i spoke to blake's and you'd be
like yo why you know what is it about
the xbox equals i could write a book on
the rules i get the rules but but this
but unfortunately
we got to be real with the fact that
those cinematic you know
over-the-shoulder
aaa experience that sony does so well is
doing well right so to have at least a
couple of those in their talk gave
people who may not have been interested
in the xbox ecosystem so i'm like okay
i'm thinking about coming over now and
then to jaffy's point you know it really
affects the balance of game pass in that
cadence of having things in there now
let's just get to the nitty-gritty my
thing is this like
me personally i'm just gonna assume i
have no inside information
i feel that bethesda may have approached
them and said this thing's not ready
right now at the end of the day this is
where me and jeffy align
no one cares
because they're going to say i want what
i want and i've been waiting right and
this is the fact that you was told right
and the reason why it's such a severe
blow because it feels like that old xbox
one energy and and solve you gonna
appreciate that it's like we met well
i'm a mess fan right and you when you're
a fan of a team with some oh it's like
they slip on the banana be like
something always goes wrong with this
was the snatch snatch defeat from the
jaws of victory right so it just seemed
like this year was lined up for them you
know what i'm saying i'm just like man
like how did this happen so i understand
and to jaffa's point you know i don't
obviously i disagree with them on the
field part but i do
at this point we have to say based on
the information that is presented i
can't get mad at jaffy or anyone who
says mismanagement because what what
pres what else do we have to go by you
know what i'm saying that that's where
it unfortunately they've put themselves
in this position now that people are
going to question hey what's going on
over there what's going on with this
studio what's going on this issue how
come you can't unfortunately perception
sometimes becomes reality based on
what's going on listen nothing's going
to replace starfield in my opinion but
i got some suggestions
i got some suggestions of what you could
do
listen to this on a t-shirt
listen
we're ready we don't need nothing
i'm joking i don't know but look at the
other day that's what you do man
it's times like this off
you got phil's gotta go get
the xbox matrix of leadership we gotta
rise we gotta we gotta you gotta play
the stan bush music we got to we got the
time
you got the
if we don't always said this what you
got to do because here's the thing
morale is low and this is why
i will give i believe this is why i
think he can turn it around this is what
i think you do because he's been in this
situation three times before one
the xbox one the x-series x launch like
jaffe said they came out with a console
that didn't have the first party game
that was on the back of the box right
that's devastating right so i said short
term what you got to do you got to free
up put some third party releases that is
going to align day and date with the
launch like who's like the dragons a
couple other games they they tried from
a third-party standpoint because you
know they didn't have the first party
they even got your acoustic exclusive
right
then what they did was they did the ea
play deal right so all of ea stuff went
in there right and then what really is
the magic it had to people forget is the
actual bethesda's nmx acquisition
because now it takes pressure off it's
like yo we bought this you know saying
look at the hope look at the food so
people now forget like oh my god we
haven't said it back to bethesda
situation two where i feel phil did a
great job of kind of rallying the troops
was again now we're coming off 2021
blackout where we sit there we like man
they had a great year psychonauts forza
horizon whatever whatever but i told
people sony is coming at the top of 2022
when when turismo horizon forbidden west
and god of war which we assume like when
they hit
and microsoft we looked at that first
half because we assumed at that point
red fall in starfield was coming and
that first half looked that barren i
think we we assumed stalker too and
stalking was supposed to be right and i
don't put no blame on stalker ukraine
situation we know what's going on we're
not going to go crazy there but what i'm
going to say is it became a situation
like yo what are they going to do for
the first part of the year and once
again
here came the activision blizzard
announced all right and all of a sudden
it's like oh my god they have this and
you don't use potential
exactly call of duty and and and
blizzard games and all this stuff and it
takes the pressure off i kind of
unfortunately they're in the same
situation again so the only short-term
fixes i could think of is okay exactly
what javi said you have to attach
yourself
to every major third-party release and
somehow get that day and date and game
pass now whether it be if you can do the
hogwarts whatever if you can do the the
gotham nights or whatever if you could
do any of the anticipated games day and
date
you're good to go because at least it it
helps ease that there's some reason
to give it gives you the perception
you're getting this for free
to jaffy's point the college the crowd
yeah because they they're in they're in
bed already it's just a matter of right
you know right you have to pay yourself
ahead of time
real time cool but if you get if you can
get right modern warfare 2 right
the one of the most anticipated call of
duty's especially coming off of vanguard
like you get that in game past day one
right
if there's somehow you could do i don't
know if they could do it because sony
with them i don't know but if they can
right that would be a huge boom the
second thing is i feel rehearsal talks
about ubisoft plus for a long time now's
the time to kind of bake that into the
service you know if you can if you're
able to if you're able to speed the
negotiation somehow make that similar to
the ea play deal when you're not like
you're gonna purchase ubisoft because
let's be honest they're under the
microsoft from the activision thing from
an ftc whatever but
that's a huge boom and then the third
thing look man it's like you're in a
relationship
and you know the boyfriend or girlfriend
you know keeps saying they're gonna
change and they don't change and they
keep doing the same thing and you're
like oh it's the same thing
sometimes you gotta put a ring on it man
you might have to do one of them wv
acquisitions man you might have to call
up netherrealm
something smart like smaller scale to
show like hey we're still investing in
this ecosystem to give the hope back i
know listen nothing's going to replace
starfield red fall that's just the
reality it's just that that's in my
opinion i i want to i want to see what
the show is i don't know hopefully they
have surprises hopefully they do it i'm
wrong i don't know i'm just going to go
based on what we know in the information
presented and that's all it is it's sad
because the perception of optics have
put them in this situation and it didn't
need to be that if there was any way and
we have to give sony credit in this way
they always have whether it be the third
party time deals or they always have
something in place to kind of make their
yearly cadence from an exclusive
standpoint still stand up and i think
microsoft is going to have to make an
adjustment but that's what i actually
they know how to like they know how to
like
appeal to the public like when it comes
to the public just anticipation they
know how to like really capitalize on
right likes there are still people are
still waiting for that psvr to showcase
right all right we haven't got anything
for that um
jeffrey then we gotta move on for this
topic part of me feels like the only
real out to this
is the the
the game pass games because i feel like
if they announced another purchase
before activision people are gonna say
you're just showing me more studios
where's the games i think that's gonna
get more of a magnifying glass on the
issue because now it's like you're not
showing us games you're showing us
something more to that point
i to that point if they show a lot of
gameplay on the 12th of whatever they're
going to show if they show actual
gameplay and it's looking next-gen
whatever and it's impressive yeah i
think that helps them a lot yeah they
they got they put they kind of have a
very they got to have an amazing show
let's be honest like they put a lot of
pressure on yeah look that's all i got
so let's get a couple of these oh jeff
jeff jeffy i'm sorry
i do agree with the addict i i think the
only other thing i'll say is it's it's
like when you talk about the abused
spouse syndrome you know i tweeted i
tweeted the other day
and only like two people got the joke
they were like what is this it was a
picture of ike turner and tina turner
and then i said and i said tina turner
is the gamers xbox gamers and ike turner
spencer and then in the middle i had a
piece of cake and i said the cake was um
xbox 2022 and you have to you know it's
basically eat the cake anime right right
that's that's you know
the fact that
your three solutions are all good and i
agree with all three of them but the
fact that nowhere in there
was it's like phil gets out of jail free
every time he spends daddy's money
buy this buy that buy that but
why xbox fans are defending
him
instead of saying
somebody
get the man some [ __ ] help i i think
i know why why
that is what the problem is
this visionary
some help steve jobs wasn't the guy
going in there and programming the mac
but he was the one with the vision and
then he hired great a players i
understand your point the facility why
it's crazy to me that xbox people are
coming at me
because i'm attacking
a system that's easily fixed
and they just it's like
i i don't get it no i'm going to tell
you why i'm going to tell you why and i
i understand your philosophy i
understand where you're at i truly do
yeah i think
why it's that way is because
xbox fans look at 2017
2018 the xbox one era
and there was really no hope they're
coming off the ps4
really being in a dominant position from
a hardware standpoint the used game drm
fiasco the whole thing the xbox brand
was it was really doing bad and what
happened is from what we know internally
terry myerson and those guys or whoever
that did not believe in xbox as as
something to even be investing in right
was like why are we even doing this so
the reason why phil is beloved in the
way is is because he was able to get a
seat at the table to say no we need to
invest in this and here's why and here's
this game pass thing and we could pivot
this way so i think that's why it's like
okay
it's kind of like the the optimus prime
you know the darkest hour thing because
at that point people knew it was on the
brink because even us questions like do
they even believe in the console
business anymore is this something they
truly want to do so that's why now to
your point i don't know what's going on
with the management i don't it could be
everything you said it could be i don't
all i'm saying is i'm willing
to give it a chance for one
not getting games released broken and
messed up that's just me you know what
i'm saying and two
the vision
if it goes according to plan right if it
was a perfect world this is a great
vision but to your point they gotta
execute and i don't know what's going on
all i can hope is see what happens on
sunday and all i say is for people who
are frustrated shout out to man fawns a
couple of people i get it like you hey
you know what i'm saying they're not
doing it for you you out you know say to
me it's either you in or you out i think
what when i'll let you go at it the last
thing i'll say is that
if i don't see any if i'm a person
that's into something and i don't see
any type of change or any type of vision
then yeah i'm out but i do see it and i
do see it that this thing could line up
but it's up to them to execute i think
where it comes from is where they came
from like carl said like
they he was able to put the xbox in such
a unique position where it's got all
these studios it's got this game pass
structure and
until i see some of these games like the
star fields and the outer worlds too i
have to reserve my judgment then because
back when i was judging him
he ended up showing me that look i we
said he we need more studios ain't
enough studios he sat there he's all
right iop i got you right and then we
got more studios so until i started
seeing the games come out which i get it
right he's still got to land the playing
though at it these games got to be good
these games got to be fired for all his
weight games
the games come out agree i can't really
truly criticize it now if the games come
out and they're bad right they'll have a
different conversation i'm like bro come
back home
we gonna talk and we're gonna be like
what you said right it's just like yo
because we waited for what right and i
get you it it's
it's it's a crazy situation that's why
we say
you can all like anyone that says i've
waited all this time go play somewhere
else i get it
they got to prove
to you that it is worth coming back to
their brand and if you got to wait for
starfield go to drop next year before
you invest in the xbox one i totally
understand y'all feel that nothing look
we got to get the super chess bro we
gotta go we have to cut the topic
they're a lot yeah but we got it we've
got to get them bro they've been i gotta
pee go go you do that yeah go handle
that go ahead do that all right
we got a boon t two dollar super chat
wag one i'll be enough respect
thank you sir
and we got d nasty five dollar super
chat question for jaffe as jaffy goes to
relieve himself how much involvement
have you had in the upcoming twisted
metal tv series i believe the answer to
that is zero mm-hmm
just to be the same side
then we have hollow member for one year
thank you sir appreciate that we got
lord metroid member for eight months
shout out to you sir salute to the lords
in chat salute to jaffe god of war two
ps2 is still my favorite in this season
get up while you read these super chats
go go go get it get it working out
everybody work it out cog looking like
schwarzenegger with the promos
gg 15 off this week y'all get that
powder you know what i'm saying that
focus get that food we should get that
hydrate get that powder cause you know
we got that white
then we got mr two opinionated two
dollars of attack who knew t.c carson
was the voice for kratos is that it
who's the voice for kratos on the
playstation i forget christopher judge
christopher johnson oh no not 2018
before that oh i forget i don't know oh
the dude from living uh
sing life yes that's right yeah yeah
yeah that's right t.c carson yeah i
think that's him
yeah yeah yeah
kushik talukdar with the 20 pound super
chat uh hello lords my dad is in prison
now i'm so stressed i feel like the
whole world is on my shoulders but
watching you guys talk about games and
having fun reminds me that everything
will eventually be okay thank you
anything we can do just to bring a smile
that's all it makes for sure for sure
and we got yeah baby farmer
five dollar super chat great game but i
think uh god award 2018 is a re-skin
they needed a recognizable face for
whatever game that was that was supposed
to be okay
that we got fonz fonzarelli gaming
remember for 12 months
uh love jaffe's candidness i don't
always agree with the man but i respect
him a hundred percent really appreciate
his thought-provoking takes
yeah yeah then we have hugh with the
two-pound super chat cog and david how
do you keep your teeth so white
salute to brushing my teeth thank you
for actually brushing them thank you
checkups thank you sir
that we have hard to find two dollars
super chat
lords they are not jaffee's gonna jaffa
yes he is yes he is that's why we love
him he's authentic to who he is then we
have matt tichbon a member for five
months down to you sir great seeing
jaffe on iop love his no-nonsense
non-biased takes on things this guy is
the gamer's gamer big respect for
everything he's done no doubt absolutely
then we have matt tichbon again 10 pound
super chat with the star field and red
fall delays does xbox need to plug the
gap with third party day and date or
does game pass already have enough value
i see it as that that would that 120 of
value just dropped out of this calendar
year yeah
well very valid
then we have fox hop smash with the five
dollars that's the homie
yo iron lords and jaffee i just want to
thank jaffe for his work twisted metal
was such an amazing series i loved them
so much as a kid ah
shout out to sweet tooth
so this is uh is is david back yeah he's
mad
okay yeah they wanted to know his
involvement with the what is it the tv
series or something oh yeah yeah uh
before we move on to this next one uh
jaffee they want to know if you had any
sort of involvement with the upcoming
twisted metal tv series
no comments uh
[Laughter]
then we have paris lockhart shout out to
you sir with the 100 super super chat
shout out to the iron lords and the
podcast there's way too much toxicity in
the industry and for someone in jaffe's
position to come out and say what he
said feels
feeds into it to question the timelines
on releases is fair but for you to hold
on a second i have to scroll
my apologies but for you to attack part
one and then it jumps to the next one 20
stupid chat someone personally and then
tell them to get therapy is wrong
everyone is going through something and
your tone is off base not looking for
you to apologize just looking for folks
to be better we can all be better
salute to paris i'm done eating my baby
ruth can i respond to both of those
absolutely the twisted mental show um i
don't have any input on it i mean i'm
engaged with the people in fact i just
talked to the executive producer
yesterday um
but it's not like it's not like neil
druckmann on uh last of us i'm not
writing it i'm not exactly producer i
know it's going though i know it's going
to start filming i think i can say this
i mean i think it starts filming next
week in new orleans
um or the week after i mean it's very
it's it's greenlit they've got the cast
they just i think announced
the woman who was the main voice in
disney's encanto and she was also in
brooklyn nine-nine i think is going to
be the main female lead
along with howard mackey um
so it's moving it's gonna be a thing i i
hope to to you know do a cameo or
something we've talked about but
i i haven't read any scripts or anything
i i like the people who they've pulled
in
but to make it the karate kid guys i
love cobra kai
love deadpool you know so i think we
have a really good team let's go oh yeah
well yeah but i hate they moved it up
though i loved that it was the new
year's thing you know after what they
did with terry silva i'm okay
i know i know
[Laughter]
are you wait are you saying you don't
care anymore or you're no no no i'm okay
with what they what what they've given
us with season four and how well terry
silva oh yeah i was brought back i'm
like dude
i'll let it go because this is basically
the plot of uh
uh credit kid three remember yeah but
they're gonna break they're gonna
they're gonna bring in uh uh hillary
swank to bring break crease out of jail
i don't know but they gotta bring crease
back from mike that might be mike barnes
back oh yeah that's absolutely yeah
[Laughter]
and i loved it when when daniel's wife
slapped uh chris
called him a psychopath he's like i like
that i like that she's like bam
she's
um
so yes but i'm excited about it but i'm
not like heavily involved but they keep
me abreast
uh the other guy all i can say is i
don't really care what you say um in the
sense that
i'm not attacking anyone personally i am
a customer i am a owner of xbox uh of
the hardware uh i am a gamer i am
passionate about the hobby in the
industry in the art form um
saying someone needs therapy is not an
insult that is more of a problem with
our society and that is more of a
problem with
i guess as addict was saying maybe with
men in general if you think there's
something shameful about needing to sit
down and have a
professional
uh
doctor work with you to figure out some
of the stuff that you're not dealing
with
that's that's a pr that's a you problem
pal saying someone needs therapy is
actually a kind thing phil spencer
the bug stops with phil
and the buck
is
not working so good right now so
and it hasn't been working for a while
this is not a one-off there's something
going on in his psyche that creates the
brilliance that he is and the the balls
that that man has to sort of really try
to disrupt the industry and that same
thing probably is also working to keep
him from going you know what i need some
help i'm not good at all of this so
tough sorry you don't like that sorry
you want to be better this is how we'd
be better we actually genuinely get to
the root of things and say stop thinking
therapy is shameful that's how we get
better not by platitudes
jeffy's smoking
we we we go back i i totally resp that's
where you're at with it and let's move
on
we got hard chinese five dollars to be
chat unfortunately for zenni and bgs
they are now caught up in a console war
if they were on their own no one would
be this upset with the delay it's sad
yeah that's kind of true although i
don't know that i don't know that red
fall exists without microsoft behind it
um pragmatic eagle member for 30 months
thank you sir not the pragmatic
respect to iop respect to david jaffe
i've enjoyed this interview enjoyed his
straightforward answers
and we got hargett cheney once again 10
super chat can't agree with jaffe on
crunch being necessary he's right though
that with the shift to no crunch we
should expect longer death times in the
already too long depth times starfield 8
years in the making
absolutely then we have donald taco 10
super chat with 30 plus studios after
activision blizzard king the no crunch
philosophy will work out once the games
start to hit and they have enough games
ready to have up to six to seven year
dev cycles they should be crunching they
should be crunching now though wow okay
then we gotta argue cindy once again
shout out to hargy uh he gave up two
codes in the chat uh if you got those
codes then you're still in the chat just
say what's up um shadow warrior three
and he also put a code there for eldon
ring the global version of elderly so
fire shout out to oh salute doggy that's
the man salute
then we have cutane clan
[Laughter]
thank you
i finally gotta go oh okay you can't
claim everybody shout out to you you got
a quote um i appreciate you i also great
show iron lords and thank you david
jaffe salute
then we have ham solo 10 super chat it's
not about delays your backlog game pass
starfield red fall yada yada yada this
is about xbox standing on the stage and
not delivering at the end of the day if
you've been a fan this long you should
not you should know
that we have gamer by choice five
dollars in chat i play games almost
every day and if i could care less
if first party games are not released as
long as i have games to play great show
salute
then we have doobie member for 18.
another great show and this week with
the legend david jaffe yes also great to
have sob back thank you sir yes reading
super chats correctly now the super
chats should be on point
no then we got kids move member for 24
months star field 3 3 23 stop putting
dates on things move this is what
happens this is the problem
you're the problem smooth
now we got cw
remember uh two dollar super chat best
xbox game franchise is the waiting game
wow wow y'all messy absolutely very
messy very interesting then we have
donald taco 10 super chat i just don't
see the point of complaining because we
know once xbox finally blows its load
it'll never stop blowing its load until
the industry is covered it's covered in
phil spencer's dot dot dot bro
we do it don
what are we doing
very very very very messy literally
messy literally messy continue
ah hold on let me scroll back a little
bit
we got a couple back here give me one
second so we have
four's a legend member for 30 months
absolutely
xbox is fine we haven't even seen the
game show and people are losing their
minds now 2023 will be scary will be
scary hours if everything lines up for
2023 just saying that is true we've been
saying that for a couple of years now
everything lines up and things come out
in 2023 yeah but we gotta execute we
gotta actually could be a lot exactly
then we have horizon herbs with the 35
the same thirty five dollars
i think it's about time microsoft drops
that bag for persona and final fantasy
vii remake on game pass by sega yeah i'm
just trying
i don't know that i don't know
what to hear yeah yeah yeah here we go
move it to a tower let's go that's the
argument between videos
[Laughter]
then we have mr irishman with the five
pound super jack if i get this rumored
gears remastered collection this year
starfield can stay in the bushes i love
my burgers fries and [ __ ] shout out to
that i feel that's i get the reference
salute
and i think we are cool no i see 14 with
the 30 minutes
and then i got the merch and then we
move on i'll come by the last okay
gaming forte member for 30 months where
is my boo boo king instead i can express
my love completely in front of the great
david taffy i'll make it up next week
love you guys thank you you go over to
fine go to fun express your love there
yes
he'll hey forte you back on that oh
salute real quick just a couple of birds
purposes uh someone please leave your
name you got the red iop shirt you
didn't say anything but salute to you
and then he also bought the off the iron
lord hoodie salute okay shout out to rip
snorter brought the beatty the iop
what
rip snorter rip snorter
rock this out at fan fest australia all
the way from australia love the show
lads keep crushing it salute to you so
look we'll combine these two because
otherwise we'll be a six-hour show we
try to destroy everybody's bladder here
um look we got two ones god of war
ragnarok and then also we wanted to talk
about
should we get this off the um comments
kind of like uh from the uh sony cfo in
a reference to
the whole um
basically game pass and if they would uh
basically say basically saying insisting
that triple a game quality would
deteriorate if uh sony adopts a game
pass style strategy and i believe this
was sony cfo hit corey to talk to toki
can't pronounce it yeah but um yeah so
pretty much he had made some comments
there triple a titles of playstation 5.
if we distribute the subscription
service we need to shrink the investment
needed for that this will deteriorate
the first party title quality and that
is our concern we want to make sure we
spend the appropriate appropriate
development costs to have solid products
and titles to be introduced in the right
manner so um yeah that was another big
hot point so we want to get these first
so let's start with you lord jaffe
guard of war ragnarok
one do you think it's coming this year
and then um two obviously if we got to
talk a little bit about obviously your
your thoughts on the dlc being a dlc to
you and like do you still i'm assuming
yes but i gotta ask you because we
haven't talked in a while do you stand
on that still and um and then we'll get
into the story so let's start with
regardless first um well okay i don't
have any inside information that it is
or isn't coming right there's not
there's when i say i don't think it's
coming it has absolutely nothing to do
with the fact that i'm like there's no
way that game's coming it's it's not
it's nothing like that it would not
surprise me
if the game ships
this year in terms of just
it was corey coming out and making that
video right that made me go i don't
think this game is coming
nothing before then it was corey's video
what's that i said it was out of the
blue him just saying hey we have nothing
for you guys yet well and the fact that
he didn't reiterate 2022 and then
the fact that you're going to have a pr
sanctioned
video that's going to go out on the sony
santa monica blog i think it was on the
playstation blog as well i don't
remember
and it's for 420
and
he talked specifically about ragnarok
but he doesn't mention
2022
but then later in the day you've got
people who are
hierarchically left lower than corey on
the totem pole in terms of what they may
know
that are not tweeting out sanctioned
playstation tweets just going no it's
still coming still coming and you would
think at that point pr would have gone
oh crap
if it's still coming in 2022 and we
still stand behind that and there's no
question
we forgot to have cory say something and
it's causing a lot of people to wonder
let's get out there with a message and
say by the way hey it's cory again
tweeting it out forgot to say yeah of
course 2022 is gonna rock you're gonna
love your christmas presents it's gonna
be awesome but there's nothing
right so that's exceptionally unusual
uh for a game that is supposed to be out
and that they're confident in so i i
think it's
got to put a percentage what'd you think
i think there's like a 90 chance i said
i would wear them i said i said i would
wear a maga hat wow on my stream for a
week and i and and i would not explain
it so it wouldn't be like at the
beginning of each show i'm like look i
hate trump i'm super progressive but
this is a punishment i'm just going to
do it you bet the d for this game
release that
i mean i didn't bend the knee i just
think it's like look you either know me
or you don't if you think i actually i
don't know donald trump
um
but but but but yeah so i i don't think
it's coming not because i'm like oh i
have some insight into development that
you don't
but because that's
pr had a couple of chances to do what pr
does which is control the message and
they didn't do it with corey they didn't
do it after it was clear the audience
was confused if it was still 2022 or
2023
um they just kind of gone quiet on it
okay that means they either don't know
or they know
and they are waiting for the right time
like let's blow people away in june for
example with visuals and in the gameplay
and then say
march 2023.
but maybe not maybe they're going to
blow us away in june and drop a trailer
that says november
you know fifth i don't i don't know but
i i if they're not then i would say i've
never seen sony pr be this sloppy
because it's really weird and do you
think there's a chance now with the red
fall and the star feel kinda out of the
picture is it a chance for them to you
know they smell blood sharks might be in
the water if it was really or could that
potentially accelerate or they just
operate independently you don't think
they have to operate independently
because ultimately you either have a
playstation and xbox if you if you have
both like i have both
i'm playing both it's not like i'm like
i wasn't going to buy god of war
it's like you know
you know if you can afford both consoles
you can probably afford their big games
of of the holidays
i i think red red what is it called red
fall
you love this title
it's just like you know if you look at
arcane and i'm a huge harvey smith fan
he was one of the key designers on deus
ex which one of my favorite games um but
you know dishonored
it's it's colt
uh uh what's the new one they just put
out on playstation exclusive um
it's colt
um it's like there's nothing about red
fall that makes i haven't heard people
like talking about like if this wasn't
an xbox exclusive right people would be
like oh my god red fall the one that
just came out on playstation day one uh
uh it's free to play what's that game
the vampire the vampire the oh red lines
bloodhounds yeah it's really good i
played it it's really good but it's not
like people are like xbox needs their
bloodline it's like nobody cares about
red fall no fair enough fair enough so
the second part the dlc statement do you
stand on that and where you at now is
the world title process
i assume i don't even know what i would
have heard actually messing with that i
have to ask but the only problem with it
is is yes of course i still stand on it
but
what people won't
listen to when i say it's like if you
are going by
you're deaf not yours i don't know what
yours is but a lot of people have said
to me our definition of dlc is it's like
an insult right just kind of like
therapy i don't think therapy is an
insult
but but what i'm saying is i'll do that
sometimes where people will
and when i come in good faith and say no
no you don't understand
when i say dlc this is i'm not giving it
a slight i i said god award 2018's my
favorite games in the last five years i
loved it um
i'm just saying dlc to me means it looks
like more of the same gotcha and and so
yes i still stand by that but i'm sure
that will change when they give us a new
trailer and they show us a bunch of cool
new [ __ ] we got you so based on what you
see right now that's where you're at
with it right and based on how i use the
term dlc but people people don't hear
that and go they misconstrued it and
flip it yeah well they they have their
own definition and when i say your
definition is not mine
that part they just don't understand
that's the better way to say it they
don't care to hear that part they
understand it they're not idiots they
just don't want to hear that part but
i'm like yeah but if you're basically
saying dlc is lesser
and dlc is synonymous with being kind of
you know not as uh uh kind of a uh
shovelware or something lesser than
i would never say that about that game
it looks awesome for what it is it's not
fair enough fair enough and final point
in reference to the sony cfo saying look
you know if we adopt game pass strategy
our triple a you know developer would be
that would deteriorate like what what's
your thoughts on that so i think sony uh
sony's had a good run
and they are aware i think because you
hear what's happening with their service
games they're spending a lot of money on
bungie to help them with this
they're spending money to get 10 studios
to make this they know i think
just like sean laden said the the the
day you know forget people saying game
pass is not sustainable i think game
pass
is probably quite sustainable but that
said though if it works um but i think
the frequency of dropping the kind of
aaa sony is dropping uh in those genres
i think that's coming to an end not
those games right but the frequency and
the frequency yeah because yeah if you
are a
uh executive and you look at the money
being made
off of things that don't have to spend
as much
to make incredible amounts of money like
there's that game croc io which is like
a browser-based first-person shooter
that looks like roblox and minecraft
that just got acquired the other day um
yeah the new generation of gamers coming
up
it's free yes
easy
social
um
everything from among us to fortnite to
roblox oh god
fall guy you know i don't i i you know
so what the ceo is saying is yeah the
kind of games we've been making are not
sustainable day and date but i think
what he's not saying is that
they know that those kind of games
are not really sustainable to the degree
they've been making them in terms of
volume of them
either because you know and i think
that's a good thing actually i think you
know it's better for the media because
really i love i mean i've loved so many
first party games i've loved goshima
i've loved internal ratchet clank
um spider-man miles morales god or i i'm
not crapping on those games but you
cannot deny that a huge component of
their success and appeal is
the money thrown at the production value
um and and and that
you know that's like a michael bay movie
at that point i'm not saying those games
are as vapid as michael bay movies but
if you're building your house on a
foundation that's shaky
like that
you're only as good as your next
incredibly expensive game
um but if you build it on the
fundamentals of the medium right you can
have kirby selling three million copies
uh and it probably only cost about
thirty million dollars to make it a
fraction of that yeah and do you think
that also is why the the the pivot to
like i said the the bungee acquisition
that they're helping out with the live
service to facilitate that type of
transit if the industry moves in that
direction
yeah you if you're an executive and you
don't see the writing on the wall you're
a really bad executive yeah the writing
on the wall is the money to be made and
the games that the audiences are
responding to stress zelnick who's the
ceo of 2k
literally just had his contract redone
and a big part of it is you're going to
make the most money if you
create an uptick in recurrent spending
which is micro transactions dlc
season passes ea last quarter made 71
percent of their money from uh
service based games if you're sitting
around thinking that the future is
15 20 hour narrative games yes those
will continue to be made and they should
and they're wonderful but that's going
to be a small much smaller piece
basically that's a good point great
answers big cloud god of war ragnarok
this year yes or no and sony cfo
statements what you feel about as far as
god of war is concerned um we'll see
what's up in june
i do think it's going to happen still
this year just because uh
there's really no competition for him so
now's the time if you don't want nothing
to interfere with a game like this
why not just ride it out go all out
through the holiday do that throughout
the holidays go go into 2023 drop that
back boy right quick reason why and the
reason why i said that lucky at uh
horizon forbidden once horizon forbidden
west didn't do so well
trying to go against oh
so you think it's imperative because the
lane is clear for the most part and like
jaffee's saying like again
even these like you know these 15-hour
like aaa budget games right they the
other market for them but
i would say like those those games
they're good for the moment you know i
mean jeffy like their good flight that
that that one particular moment you need
an ongoing type of service thing to be
really all out here to compete like
non-stop so god of war doesn't have that
and god forbid they try to put that in
there because they did it before with
ascension and didn't really do so uh
well for him so i do think that's going
to drop this year i have really no fear
for god or right now because i think
that would be good
i'm going to wear a red hat
[Laughter]
to 2023 i'd be like okay
sony cfo in this whole gaming service i
mean you know
again the thing about sony and again
this is the same thing applies to the
fans everybody can just attest to this
because y'all have seen it multiple
times um a lot of people have the
mindset where if it's not broke don't
fix it type of thing so everybody's used
to the singing particular strategies
whether it be for example
something simple like the ps3 gym when
we have like a bunch of games in a year
for this you know the first party or
what sean layton wanted to do where it
was a game in each quarter yeah i
remember that was like one game free
supporter um everybody likes that
particular thing so when they see change
they're like oh i'm not with that you
know i'm used to what i'm used to i'm
used to using
oh geez i hold it on oh geez yeah a lot
of people want that og type of feel but
the thing is um
and i said this multiple times i even
got flight for it so jeffy don't don't
feel weird that you get worked out
that's i had dudes calling me an xbox
and i'm a big playstation guy you like
the difference
i know
that's how dudes right so going back to
it again when you look at the just the
way the the industry is going
don't get me wrong it's cool to have the
the first party games that's not ever
going to change but the weird part about
it is people just need to understand
sony's in that predicament where they
don't really have a game like like
beforehand sony kind of masked the
problem right they had relied heavily on
call of duty to be their multiplayer
shooter yeah great great third-party
marketing deals in association with the
even destiny themselves before they
acquire bungie is that synonymous with
sony right it's like we can't beat them
let's just uh that's wrong with them you
know i mean let's get the most out that
particular deal that's basically what
they did
now you see them in a predicament where
they have former call of duty devs
making a next call of duty and now you
have bungie itself helping you with the
core you know thing that you really
really need that's multiplayer games and
i'm pretty sure they're going to help
out with networking as well for the
games as well because you know that's
also something that hasn't really been
their greatest strong suit but when you
hear 10 games as a service right and jim
ryan go back to jim ryan him wanting uh
new and existing franchises and they
brought that back multiple times i do
see socom getting that next um you know
gets the next set of legs i can see
resistance fallen man coming back and
getting that next fall you know set up
so
that's where i kind of see it it's like
you know
does it hurt the games no i don't think
it hurts the games
options are you know
me saying options are bad no that's
that's not the point like options are
good you having the option to play a
game or experience it on a cheaper rate
is good now a lot of people have this
idea where value
versus
i guess game pass right on the
playstation side like i've seen do say
playstation has the best value ever with
the old playstation premium thing i mean
you're paying
the biggest amounts out of everybody in
here on top of that you have to buy it
just to get the discount
microsoft you're paying a little still
getting the discount and getting more
potentially
essentially out there with it you know
two-hour game trials
for a game versus a full-fledged
playthrough of a game for 15 hours a
month
i think the masters are gonna choose
fifteen dollars a month
game pass is the best demo disc in the
world
to sustain the the cadence the quality
games in it though but i i definitely
understand where you're coming from from
about from a pure value perspective we
can't deny what they can pass yes you
know what i'm saying i mean it's going
to get better over time when they start
dropping the main stuff in here sure
like when we start seeing those um you
know those next dooms the elder scrolls
the
um the fables all that stuff when it
eventually drops sure
that is going to get even better but
right now i would say and i would agree
with everybody that there needs to be
more thrown into uh game pass and really
what game pass is really missing is that
next year like um you know game to go yo
this is our our poster boy so to speak
for it and call of duty falls right in
line with that where you tag it with it
and go hey by the way not only do you
not pay seventy dollars for this or
sixty dollars for this first fifteen
dollars you get the full game and guess
what yeah we also get all the dlc yeah
my friends we know those guys call of
duty bannon 2k and they good for the
year
we know those guys i i know those guys
but it's the main thing they buy for it
they buy for the call duties they buy it
for the maddens the nba 2k so i mean
that's what i mean
so if you can get all those in there
you're pretty much set no doubt lord
addict the two-headed real quick
god of war ragnarok yes or no coming out
in 2022 and sony cfo talking about game
pass not really sustainable for them
they quality would deteriorate pardon me
thinks it's like a 50 50. kind of
leaning more towards it doesn't come out
because
we're almost june and we still haven't
really heard nothing
um
i was on the the hill i died on the hill
why did it die
which one around me
so it's just like look like
the question is is sony going to break
the we don't really release too much
stuff in november or october
are they breaking that if they're not
breaking that it's coming out next year
if they are breaking that it's coming
out this year the only reason i'm giving
it 50 50 is because a lot of developers
and some uh i think a community manager
said it's coming out this year and
usually i feel like
after that first person said it if sony
didn't think that game couldn't come out
this year i feel like they would have pr
would have reached out like shut your
mouth
like i felt like they probably would
have put more of a tighter leash on
everyone else but it just feels like
everybody can come out and say god
awards coming out this year so that's
what kind of makes me feel like okay
maybe they do break that for for a
holiday launch and i just real quick the
the community manager thing is weird
because you know i know bruno came out
the lead animator and said 2022. i
already said what i think about that but
people are i started googling like
where's this community manager you know
it didn't come out through
sony santa monica's
official community manager tweet
right it came out through this person
who has like 4 000 followers that may be
that person i have no idea uh and and
and then they said they retweeted a few
days later the only thing that's
official
word on god of war comes from the
official account so i'm kind of like
when people bring up that community
manager bit it's like let's be clear
it's not sony santa monica's community
manager
tweeting through sony santa monica
proper resources saying it's coming out
right it's somebody's private account
that i don't even know if that is the
community manager when you go to their
site um so i'm just saying just be aware
that that's what addict's talking about
when he says community manager because i
don't i don't think it's been anything
more than that gotcha got you it's like
i said at the end of the day
are they willing to break that most the
time i think
that's stranding's the last game that
came out that late
and i think kojima probably had a lot
more say on his brand than sony did at
that time
so it's just like are they going to do
that for god of war i'm inclined to not
think so and i feel like that corey
barlog that if i've never seen a yo it's
not coming out this year but we got an
update for you then i don't know what it
is that kind of energy i got i got to
see
i would say within a month if you don't
hear within a month or at least some
kind of like date for some state of play
it's coming out next year yeah i think
jeffrey's someone in the chat uh shout
out to the launching game without a g if
you think anything's coming from a sony
showcase standpoint
possibly
i mean i i don't i haven't you know i
know there's a rumor that there's one in
june i don't know if sony feels the need
to hit june given that you've got
keeley's thing already and you've got uh
microsoft's thing june is awesome i am
excited like i'm more excited for june
sitting in front of my computer and
streaming than i am because because
because e3 used to be brilliant and e3
just became an awful experience but now
i mean really if you look at there's the
pc gamer show there's keeley show
the xbox there's the xbox thing and
they're probably are gonna end up being
four or five more
what a neat way to have a new e3 it's
just everybody can come the only thing
better and again going back to the pc
thing which i think is amazing is
what's cool about a lot of these now is
if you have pc because xbox and
playstation don't really have that
infrastructure it's such a walled garden
is that you really it's like hey this is
coming next year and you can play the
demo right now
on steam right it really does feel like
a virtual e3 if you have a computer
which is awesome so yeah i'm i'm i'm
excited for uh but i don't know if
sony's i think sony will drop but i
could see them going let's wait till
july because why would we get up in all
this mess right
and then plus let's be real here next
month's gonna be lit for content
creators so for sure for sure we're
definitely gonna be lit no
real quick uh sony's strategy you you
agree with them as far as them saying
that if they adopted a game pass kind of
model the triple a development would
deteriorate for them
i i don't think that i i know enough
about like all the
the behind the scenes stuff that game
pass does
to really justify if sony can do it or
not like i do know that one of the
reasons microsoft's able to do what they
have to do is because they have the the
financial backing to get through the
really messy beginning part
i don't know if sony has that kind of
money to that they can call on to do
that for years
and i don't know even if they did would
sony be willing to risk that kind of
money doing something like that uh so
you know i think it's just two different
things like sony wants to um they want
to continue doing what they're doing
i've said it for years they got a
certain amount of time until sony starts
until microsoft's game pass all these
studios start hitting
hopefully it's soon but once all these
uh studio starts putting out games if
they're good games sony's gonna have to
re-change stuff up because regardless if
you got a game the quality of like last
was two and it's an amazing game god of
war amazing game the best way to beat up
a bully is to take five people with you
so
it's just like you know
jump jump jump
just jump
i respect it dude so it's just like at
the end of the day we got to see
how game pass
like look we're seeing them i know game
pass has been out there for a while but
it's still a relatively new concept we
have to see how it does
once they
start kind of wanting some of this money
back that they put into it you know what
regardless in five years we got to see
how long it takes to really
realistically recuperate that money yeah
and see if that is worth the the
investment they've been doing no doubt
can i just say real quick do you know
the best way to make a bully not a bully
though and make that person better talk
to him oh my god therapy oh my god
bro
you gotta expect that he's dying on it
bro he on his squad
god of war ragnarok this year or not
it's 70 cfo gay pass back i mean
much like my feelings on star field that
uh and red fall like i don't care like
i just wanted to come out when it's good
and ready like for me the only thing
that will disappoint me about god of war
ragnarok is if it comes out and like
king and jaffee were saying before it
doesn't incorporate some of the things
from you know previous god of war games
that we've come to expect and love i
want to see the gore i want to see you
know i just want to see it to be a
little bit more over the top i like the
doubt of war angle and other people
don't like that but like jaffe said i
like it i appreciate the fact that the
guy who the guy murdered everybody who
wanted to murder and what happens when
that guy has time to reflect and think
what happens
and i think i think 2018 does that very
well um but i do want to see more
variety in the enemies
i want to see addict need more trolls
i'm at that point where i know there's
trolls in this universe i want them to
delete them i want to put in the lord
that they got like
troll colors that's what you are
very into the colors of the truth we
have kratos fighting the troll god at
the beginning kill him and get rid of
all the trolls after that like i don't
want to see no more trouble we killed
enough trolls for the decade okay good
good i wanna i say i wanna say question
about that yeah good best place well but
because my guess is the reason you saw a
lot of trolls unlike earlier games it
takes so long now
to make a character and to rig a
character and an animated character that
i'm sure they would have loved to have
had more but it would have come at a
cost of visual quality would you have
preferred
um maybe the enemies in god of war 2018
to look
30
they'd still fit in the world they'd
look like they fit but 30 25
less
great but you had more variety or would
you rather have less variety but keep
the visual and animation fidelity i
think it was for me the variety matters
a lot the variety and and the the
grandeur of the set pieces i thought was
diminished over my previous god of war
yeah that's why i got it
so i think what hit me uh jaffa i said
it uh past is i didn't like how there
was this one mission where you're pretty
much going to the hell gates and they're
they're just amping this dude up this
whole way there they're like this dude
it's a beast it's going to be in like
it's going to be an epic battle you get
to him he's a purple troll
and i i think it's like when you amp up
characters in a game while you're going
to them but you use the character you
just fought five times then it's grimace
from mcdonald's there's a problem
i'm with you i'm going to
that defend a dungeon yeah that can be a
troll but don't don't have something up
but it's just a troll well i think the
difference between him is he could
teleport that's awesome i knew he was
going to get your mind
you actually felt something when you
killed the gods in god of war three you
know yeah as you took their powers you
really like whether it be hermes for
example who trolled you the entire race
just like i can't wait to kill this dude
and when you killed him like yeah you
know it's great so i just
i do want i do want more of the game you
know because it's because the funny
thing about it is when we talk about
variety in this
um the other um bosses or the other
characters that you can fight in the
game are hidden and those are the
valkyries yeah yeah yeah
it goes back to sustainability and
triple a though it's the every time the
bar gets raised
it comes at a cost and there's not the
audience isn't growing for it and so
that's a good point uh again i keep
going back to indies it's like i know i
know a lot of people want their fidelity
their visual [ __ ] but i literally played
one of the funnest horror games of the
year last week and it was one guy made
it in unity and i get it you want to see
great look but no i know where you at i
no no i'm there with you i'm jackie i
feel the creativity i think the
creativity is there they're more apt to
take risk
and then the aaa looks at them like oh
we need to copy that
and that's how it becomes the assembly
line later but really the indie scene
like we go to pax and we go like i love
that stuff you get to see all these cool
ideas and you're like yo they're just so
creative and i know it's just
we just interviewed like like 30 dabs on
yeah and all those games i'm reviewing
one right now yeah i'm so promising but
again solving and pick last sorry age
ratio
so uh to the sony versus the game pass
strategy um i you know i agree
completely that
you know kind of with addict and what
the rest you guys have been saying where
it's like i i think fundamentally the
two approaches are different and on the
sony side you you know why try to fix
what isn't broken yet
um but understand read the you know see
the writing on the war know that you
have to invest in that at some point to
supplement
continuing to make those types of games
right um
at the same time i just don't like the
way it was talked about because it felt
very
uh in the in one breath he says
um he says i don't want to comment on
this on our you know on our on the
strategy of the uh of our sort of rivals
but at the same time he proceeds to say
that that essentially saying the game
pass doesn't work you know
that's not going to work for them um and
by saying that that you know the quality
of their types of games would diminish
in a game pass type model is essentially
saying that it just kind of just doesn't
work not necessarily just doesn't work
for you but just doesn't work and for me
it's just like you could have worded it
differently because at the end of the
day
i do think microsoft is in the special
position where there's a willingness
and ability to just keep pumping money
into game pass until it becomes super
viable then you have whatever 100
million subscribers and it's really
self-sustaining whereas like what addict
said i don't believe sony cares to do
that even if they could and then fan is
microsoft is in a unique position in a
very unique position
it's just you know and again but there
still has to be a willingness it had
from the top up if if sasha says no
we're not pumping all this money into
game pass and it's not happening right
yep so um so that's that but it just for
me
it could have been worded differently
because it goes back to like the jim
ryan quote about the virtuous cycle of
that you know oh we're doing something
it's stupid and i get stupid when you
say like you know the way we make games
would be you know adversely affected by
trying to you know shoehorn them into
this this sort of into this this
subscription
they
at the end of the day i understand
how financially behind the scenes
you say okay i'm not going to invest as
much money into this because it's not
going to come back in the way that a 70
you know uh a la carte purchase would i
get that at the same time if the quality
is diminished that's on you you choose
to diminish the quality because the
returns wouldn't be the same and i get
that word it that way don't make it seem
like it's just
yeah that doesn't work
no and never say virtuous cycle again
because it sounds like it sounds like
you're talking about your wife's period
is what it sounds like
when i heard that i was so disgusted
because i'm like you see
and you wonder why fanboys exist you you
this this is
but
i think it's a side of intelligence if
you know your base loves you talking
that way
because i know that i no longer fit in
that world because i could not shovel
that horse yes
i couldn't i wanted to be honest i'd say
exactly what sovereign just said you're
absolutely right i said sure you could
keep making the games but and you can
make the quality go up but you're taking
a big risk that you're going to grow the
audience because of that decision to
sustain the loss that you would take
because the budgets have gone up but but
he's not going to say that he's going to
talk about you know the virtuous cycle
it's a purity of the
and if king were here king would say
it's just because they too broke to do
it
and and you know
and he isn't wrong in the sense that i
don't think
the amount of money that microsoft pumps
into game pass is not something that
nintendo would care to do that sony
would care to do right you know and
they're taking a risk and hoping that
you know in a couple of years game pass
does reach a hundred thousand a hundred
million subscribers and then you know
what it then it's it it really is
self-sustaining at that point and i'm
back and the lord told me oh my god we
we've been going this long that we got
you back up
really podcast
i did a whole show i came back i gave
you your flowers over there and i'm back
crap i'm so glad you're back i don't
even know what the hell
oh man he you're lucky he left oh my god
yes so what the what was they saying so
basically they said that the model is
not
you know their aaa development would
deteriorate
my mind yeah this is going to be crazy
you talking about sony talking that
stuff yeah yeah and they said that um if
they were to adopt a game pass strategy
and putting first party titles good for
them okay
if for them right now that doesn't make
any sense right now when they have a fan
base that's willing to pay 70 right
they're vocal on we want to pay 70 and
we want to support the developer right
i'm not gonna
no until you tell me no we want it here
no i'm gonna keep giving it to you just
like how you want it pulse um
but at the same time
they're not in that space to do that
right i think with more developers and
with a more fleshed out uh uh games of
service model that they're going to
uh with a lot of their games right now
that is more sustainable and starting to
get that product inside uh their service
in their platform i think it'll work
that way but right now no ones and dones
no
no
i don't think that and you missed the um
do you think god will go right and rock
this year 2020 no i don't know okay no
it's not i don't know i think i think it
uh slips to the end of the year i mean
it is dlc right so yeah
he was waiting to get alive with
japanese
the fact come on man you saw the same
ogre so
oh my god they showed you on the board
you couldn't get to asgard but asgard
was there right so that means it was dlc
inside the game right so if i'm able to
get to asgard now that means you had
this purposely put to the side talking
about oh it's not gonna be no dlc later
you lied to me so why is aggar on on on
the table and i can't get there do you
know i thought that i would be able to
get to asgard while i was playing the
game so i thought i had more game left
and then when i saw the credits i was
like oh they done robbed me
i said i didn't get to ask god i said
time out wait a second i said maybe it
was a secret passage that i did
so let me get back to the table and flip
this table over again so i flipped the
table over again still no asgard i
flipped the table over again and you
know what it said see you at dlc it'll
be coming out in 2023. do you know all
they have to do in june if they do a
showcase for ragnarok in june is eric
williams walks out
there's him standing in the snow kratos
and on the screen he takes his
controller
he hits x
kratos jumps yo eric walks off the stage
drops the controller
it's like
yeah but
it could easily move into next year
simply because there is no trilogy this
is it yeah they're ending the story here
there's a lot of story to tell no
that's kind of crazy look i'll jump in i
don't know if it's dropping we'll see i
will say
if it does drop man that's gonna hurt
for a side that's looking for
aaa experiences that didn't get some in
twenty twenty we don't know that though
uh yeah i don't care i mean after june
we will definitely
we also know who's financially capable
of just sitting there saying you know
what and
i know david could have really loved
this part when you got f.u money
when you can walk inside the room and
throw after you money on the table
hey what's that game over there you put
that in game pass i don't care what's
dropping on there dropping on the stain
they they dropping let's put it out
there
i can see that happening yeah so
fu money changes the whole game plan
these dudes can if somebody wants to be
petty somebody wants to put on their
petty boots and they got sick and tired
of what's going on and what's being said
things can change june 12th is going to
be chris it's up to them to get that
perception as far as the second point um
i just think it's the different model
man i just think they are
they probably in their pocket where it's
like they don't want to fully commit to
the model that xbox is doing they are in
a the vibe i get they're still in the
transitionary period where it's kind of
like a one foot in one foot out hey
we're gonna do a service too we will
have a premium tier but i just don't see
it as something they're interested in
until i think they see
you know signs of some type of decline
or you know yeah like he was saying
until they see that then you know i know
there's the shortages in the stock stuff
i don't you wanted to talk about the
handkerchief we don't have much time
with that but you know it was just to me
i just think they're they're resisted to
to do that and i think that part of it
yeah is financial like let's be honest
microsoft is in a different position as
them that they can invest into this
thing and go as hard as they want to try
to build their subscriber base and build
it and with them that's just not their
motto so we'll we'll see but that's all
i got
damn we went long this is crazy though i
was able to leave and come back
and come back and catch my man
and go to do a whole show
hey is that a captain america girl
picture behind you where are you talking
about on this side yeah because she
looks like a woman
it's hard to make her out is that steve
rogers or is that like a blonde captain
america female so that's that's captain
america that's up there but you see the
scarlet witch that's under him i don't
know exactly what you're seeing in the
right hand upper right here
is right there upper right hand of the
screen with the shield and who's the
blonde girl in america that's a guy
that's a girl oh he do it do kind of
look like yeah yeah he does it like it's
like it's a
female kid
because i've seen blonde captain america
cosplay before and it's so [ __ ]
hot
and i'm just like did they release like
a print like yeah she's i love it when
captain america is a girl
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't want you to be
looking over there with those eyes no no
that's a
let god look up my favorite cosplayer
look the absolute pleasure the legend
david jaffee in the realm finally did it
brother thank you for having me an
absolute pleasure man love to hear your
journey love to hear the stories the
inspiration as far as just going from
like the film industry then switching
gears you know what i mean and then
getting into gaming and and seeing the
uniqueness in these teams that you're a
part of that like i agree with king
really shaped the identity of the
playstation brand and just hearing your
love i'm not mad we can get talked one
game again it's just been like a
six-hour show cause i want to talk about
cage but you bad like i really want to
really get into the arcade scene but
actually he went to steven spielberg's
oh
you know what i'm saying like i wouldn't
get into that bad but it was just time
but brother absolute pleasure love what
you bring to the industry love your
perspective i love that we can agree to
disagree respectfully oh yeah i love
what you're doing out here where can i
find people find you what else do you
got going on sir
david scott jaffe is where i tweet
that's the best place to find all my
stuff but if you're on youtube go over
to just type in david jaffee in the bar
the show is called gabin and games but i
think i'm going to change the title
because i can't sell any merch because
nobody wants to walk around with a
stupid shirt that says cabin and games
they don't like iron lord's podcast has
some [ __ ]
juice on it right it's like oh that
sounds kind of cool i'll walk around
with that shirt i was going to walk
around like yeah
that's cool with the jaffy coke joining
it's hot though i like the japanese
look at that i mean
yeah that's dude um but yeah so i got i
got to figure that out but right yeah if
you go over to youtube you type in
davidjaffee or i'm i'm all over the
internet but i yeah come come visit
see if you like the show see if you like
a video
and uh and we also have a discord and
all that good stuff around no doubt
pulling up in the 11th hour holding us
down during the king's field trip to
podcast came back still got it yelling
things with my friends
where can the five people find you what
else do you have going on sir oh man
it's always a pleasure man i appreciate
the uh invite as always uh good to see
sovereign's been a minute yes um nice
officially meet you jeffy again i was a
pleasure speaking with you and uh
hearing about your legacy king you
already know that's my dude right there
all in love right there you know marvel
or mr doctor strange you know what i'm
saying we got to talk about it twice
uh addie giardo my brother and of course
kai i appreciate you um for those of you
that want to find me it's big cloud
gaming pretty much everywhere youtube
twitch twitter um when i'm not uploading
um freelancing with ign and their
program that's what i do
um and i'm very happy to announce i
don't know if guys no no we could do
that we could do that
we could do that logos on the screen you
know as much as i love these guys and i
love talking with them and uh i want to
be part of the movement with them so i'm
very happy to announce that i will i'm
officially a writer now for
lord2gaming.net covering all playstation
news as well looking forward to doing
that you guys want to check it out check
me out there as well you'll find all my
interviews eventually
a lot of the connects that i've made
from this awesome industry you're gonna
expect a lot of those up there so it's
gonna be awesome awesome hey jen i told
you we're gonna poach them
i'm coming for all your writings
i'm coming for everybody
hey you want that
i'm just careful what you wish for oh my
listen i'm trying to be the new 15 cent
not 10
15
[ __ ] shout out to big clown
absolute legend man love what you doing
on the playstation side these tremendous
interviews shout out to you for the
opportunity i appreciate it oh
absolutely man we're going to work
together get you at uh
some of these uh shows these events
absolutely
love what you're doing out here killing
the game salute and of course lord attic
the young wolf where can the fine people
find you besides sitting in that hard
chair
when king showed up
actually when king showed up i expected
the show to go way longer because keane
was back so i went in there just i want
i want the room to just just visualize
this i went in there to my brother's
room he's sitting there playing i think
he was playing minecraft or world of
warships one of those games and i
snatched his chair
he told me i couldn't use it today but i
went in there i was like man i'd get
okay i had to give him ten dollars
no longer man i just couldn't do it but
i appreciate it
i appreciate it jeffy for coming on you
know might disagree with you on uh some
of your perspectives uh you know but one
thing i i do enjoy is just like it's
hard to
it's hard to balance
industry
and
to
balance
a personality and i feel like
the people that are definitely they're
like i don't care about the industry i'm
saying what i want to say
and then you get jaffy
it's just like look like and that
doesn't doesn't mean that people like
are fake or anything it's just like
sometimes you know you you
you you do have to find selective words
for certain things you can't just go
extra but jaffee don't care and i love
it i love it you know but you know
obviously you know i don't agree with
certain things but it's just like at
least i i i'm always for a passion in
the industry and as well as i do think
you could be a little bit better on your
words oh my gosh uh but you know
what to what end
because you probably don't know what
you're asking i don't know what you're
saying what i'm saying is it makes you a
little uncomfortable but you don't
really know why you don't like it and
maybe you wish you could do it too
oh no no i i i'm i'm the one that
usually speaks the most on this show so
explain to me why you wish i would
choose my words better here we go
it's not yet it's like you know we could
go into it for a couple seconds it's
like
i come in i come from a family like that
does
look at stuff like therapy as a negative
notation so i think that's why i was
saying you know choose better words now
obviously that sounds like a you problem
i know but i did i
i started that sentence with i come from
a family
that is a bad influence and it's like
you know it and i love that you you know
you you're able to to to do that
effectively without getting lighter man
if i went into therapy you know you know
how my family would look i i could i
could tell you some people right now
would disown me oh i understand
i understand
why you guys don't let a lot of white
people oh my god oh my god oh my god
of content creators
wow
it's not that jaffy it's just like i do
understand
when it comes to that particular
statement how some people would get
offended right now yeah obviously you
have a different perspective because you
and your surroundings have completely
embraced stuff like that but in my
family you use therapy when you're
trying to say something going crazy but
you know what i mean you think your
family do you think your family would
benefit from therapy oh yeah most
definitely but that's not that's not the
argument that's not the discussion
so you know what i like i like that yeah
definitely tom what i like is that at
least at the very least that what we can
do is
have the discussions right because i
think what happens is
we either try to silence people
you know what i'm saying and just not
even engage or just you know shut them
out completely and it's just like i i
don't subscribe to that you know and i'm
not going to subscribe to
oh because you know we maybe disagree on
one thing that we can't talk at all you
know what i'm saying and i just i just
miss
i don't know just society-wise that just
having those discussions conversations
yeah and i've had these talks with colin
it's just like i i really respect
respectful discourse like just hey yo
this way you act that now i got more
clarity so i hear it we don't we don't
get the uh tweet and that's it like
because we get the context and then you
get why i'm going and then cool and we
can move on but yeah i know you're about
to say i think the problem is just you
know we're just so much more connected
socially
and there's a lot of companies that just
don't want that social security of
course of course but all i'm saying is
we should we shouldn't
among friends right and we should not be
like yo
i'm i'm done with this person i i can't
even talk to this person at least hear
the person i think we don't even get to
the point we have a conversation anymore
that's the part that really bothers me
so i love it regardless you don't say
well y'all were killing me for hashtag
just weird like
i mean one of our baby bro mentality
yeah one of our key statements is like
you know we we give everyone
a pla platform to speak their mind if
something
that's one of the reasons we have
calling on here it's like look like you
can disagree with some of our guests
rightfully not want to be on the show
because colin i mean he didn't want to
watch the show because colin yeah we
were like you know what
we see you next week we see you next
week if you don't like the guests and
it's like
when you look at it from that and it's
like look like you can disagree with
some of our guests and some of our
guests
have ever justified to disagree with
them but we're still going to give them
the platform to explain what they're
talking about absolutely and i feel like
that open all of branch is something
that's not preached
preach brother that that's what i'm
proud of it's like it's like one of
those things where you know if we was
like a lot of other outlets it's like we
don't agree so you're not coming home
exactly and we even allow adults date
and sight to spend months every day with
with this with this thing out here every
chat they in here
do it doing not doing the launch work on
this family moderators please
get these guys
we understand sexy chat doc xyz we
understand yeah but um now i feel what
you said soft where can i find people
find what you got going on sir yeah big
shout out go to our brother big cloud
like you're killing it brother you're
absolutely killing it oh yeah thanks
come on big clap
do it do us proud every single day with
everything you're doing so i i
appreciate you coming on and welcome to
uh loch ness
thank you and jaffee i got to say man i
think what i appreciate most about
jaffe today
is that
there isn't i feel like there isn't a
disingenuous bone in your body
and everything it's all real it's all
real definitely it's all real and none
of it comes from a place of malice none
of it is
all of it comes from i'm saying what i
feel and at the end of the day it's
always some sort of advisory thing like
hey i've been through this
i need you to acknowledge this and i i
think
one of the big things also is the fact
that you said about was
you said that you realized that
you would not fit in gaming today which
is in on one
hand is sad right to realize that at
that level
yeah right but at the same time it you
know it takes it takes a really big
person to sort of have
invest in themselves enough to realize
that hey i'm at that point where i want
to do something different i don't
i don't want to be in this space i don't
feel like i fit in in the space and and
to acknowledge that and to do what
you're doing
it's something that
it bothers me about how people perceive
you it bothers me about how people
perceive colin is that people hear what
they want to hear and they believe what
they want to believe and a lot of times
that is based on nothing so i appreciate
you being here no i i appreciate i do
appreciate you saying that yeah no doubt
um and i just again if we do anything
message-wise for people who come in with
preconceived notions of who these people
are
listen to them listen to
what they say how they carry themselves
and and and think about any preconceived
notions you may have about them think
about the person behind it and just
really do your research about people
because there's so much of people just
they just want to label someone because
it's the easy thing to do
and it just bothers me so i'm just i'm
glad jeffy's here no doubt respectfully
lord king where can the five people find
you what's going on with you um first
and foremost i'm gonna say uh
big clown
yes sir got em
the iron bank dropped off the bag
feels good to work with a little bit of
money in your pocket be like
bring them over here
over here
i don't know about that part yet but
continue
if anybody wants a theoretical
theoretical
start to have other people yeah people
are like oh that was gorgeous
that was jack palance
oh yeah
oh okay
now i get it yeah that's awesome now i
do yeah yeah
yeah if if anybody watch tango and cash
um
to to interview
yeah idol
one of my idols like i told you he's the
one of the four what are your game in
mountain rush most you you said yes
man
yo it's
you don't
understand how you affect this little
black kid that was inside the bronx oh
you're talking to me yes sir that's you
oh get yourself take your flowers damn
it
because he was talking to big cloud for
about night i was like everyone's
talking to you no no we passed big clubs
we got him
he on board your own boy he signed on
one three you sir
you affected this little black kid that
was in the bro i was never a little
pulse
but this black kid that was inside the
bronx
uh that bet on his sony playstation
right i bet on the sony playstation at
the time where he's going to turn this
into something different
i'm not he's because i'm going to tell
you right now
twisted metal and all the other games
that you worked on that i got a chance
to notice because i went down your list
and i was like oh sweat moto
well not really that one but yeah yeah
but i mean he was in there yeah right
okay yeah
so all these games i'm looking at your
wikipedia like this guy right here
is he he he you're you formed
my gaming life my identity with the
playstation because you gave the western
market because remember at that point in
time japanese markets the jrpgs they had
that unlocked you gave them a western
face
you gave them an identity to identify
with the the hardcore edge so i
appreciate everything that you have done
in my gaming history and my fondest
memories has been of your games that you
have been involved with you have
directed and you have created so i thank
you sir so much absolutely
and and i humbly
appreciate you giving your time
for us today
i was so happy that i'm able to come
back and say this to you
and all that
did trips he ate food he did it all for
the lord
[Laughter]
i just i just want you to know that man
like
i don't i nobody says about anything at
all because i really don't listen
because i only care about what i care
about because i'm selfish
okay
right but at the same time these dudes
went out of their way to make sure that
that happens i was asleep and without
their due diligence and without us
working as a team
this this won't ever happen so i
appreciate everybody here every last
person here for for for helping one of
my little dreams come true so thank you
so much um you can catch me at combat
talk with the king saturdays at 10 pm
not this saturday because the king is
going on vacation doing this thing
um but i probably might upload a little
something we have tank versus rowley
this weekend and that's going to go up
kos is coming up uh as king of the
statues so probably i'll take a picture
of that and send that over to david
jaffe so he doesn't think he's a woman
i did see the guy in the chat saying no
i'm thinking of american dream which is
a is the female captain america just
guys i just thank you for the those are
very nice things to say uh i appreciate
on behalf of all of us who made those
games
um
i i have i have not yet learned how to
take those very kind compliments
not because i'm like insecure about it
but because i have like i said earlier i
won't i won't go over it too much but i
i have felt the same about other
creators in movies and comics and things
like that and once i became a guy that
heard those same kind of things that me
and the teams did that i used to say to
people like steven spielberg or stan lee
or whatever
um
[Music]
it's it's a very strange thing to hear
um you know people never like you say
people never get the flowers while
they're still here to smell them
um i don't know if it's possible to
smell it
i i i think the very nature of me
working with teams to make something
that we love that did connect with that
10 year old kid or that little kid in
brooklyn
[Laughter]
is correct
say that right bro hip-hop
regardless regardless
is
uh
it
you can't look at the creation of the
work
that way it goes out and it's its own
thing and so it becomes difficult to
know how do you take that because i know
exactly what you're saying right because
i was that kid
um but i don't know how to take it
because i go
that's some very important meaningful
kind wonderful nostalgic memories that
you're sharing
and i love that we can be part of them
and at the same time i want to make it
clear to people watching that that is
that is almost something that happens
subconsciously right and it's not
something we
you know what i'm saying yeah of course
of course it's a moment it's a moment
i'll jump in look man absolutely
absolute pleasure shout out to the chat
everybody in here rocking the whole way
for the most part being respectful that
crazy and uh look again jeffy i know
what you're being you know it's a moment
we definitely don't want to understate
the team aspect but we also we believe
in giving people their flowers and
you're a contributor in this industry
that we can't we can't take that away
from you no one can take that away from
you and it was great to have a
discussion with you and hopefully great
to be here thank you guys we'll be back
don't do that anytime you already know
how to talk to you jeff no doubt all
right come around get me out we got
super
oh yeah yeah absolutely absolutely yeah
there you go
so technically i'm not here i'm i'm
going to be uh jumping out all right do
your thing with that
if anybody has to go we understand we
had everybody hostage solve we'll read
the super chats and yeah we gotta we got
a couple not too many okay all right i'm
gonna head out unless there's any
specifically asking me something bro let
me see later
i mean there's some there's some people
that had it you know i'll wait i'll wait
this one is just somebody's commenting
on on your therapy thing commenting not
necessarily asking you a question what
was your comment
uh
drogba 10 super chat if everyone needs
therapy then that makes it an irrelevant
professional critique you can't use
stigmatized language to intentionally
provoke then say that same stigma isn't
your problem great show [ __ ] you oh
[Laughter]
thank you again for pulling up
appreciate you
[Music]
[Laughter]
phil is the founding titan the xbox lead
rumbling is coming for the industry on a
serious note jaffee made some good
points yes he did
then we have a grizzly seam or chrisley
keem i don't know i don't know what
they're trying to say there ten dollar
super chat last name pronounced see me
okay
chrisley see me there you go here we go
it seems like microsoft is learning how
to manage studios and this is the
growing pain stage as long as they learn
and grow from this they will be fine i
mean there's a hell of a lot of studios
to manage so
kind of unprecedented clutch man five
dollars of a chat listening late but
obviously bummed about the starfield
delay but i just have a feeling they
still have amazing games set for this
year can't wait and we got lord metroid
2 chat let's not forget god of war
trilogy superb music yes definitely dead
then we got har get chini 5 super chat
where's jamaican jim ryan get him on
here to tell us what's what why he wants
to make games bad to put them day and
date in spartacus
um
yes we got to talk at the end
can't you stick around for that too all
right little dog my wife is
there we got lord metroid two dollars
from chat jaffee if you get stuck on
metroid walls i got you okay
then we got the doctor
dollars if you check jaffy and king
should do a show together yes i would
pay money i think it would be hilarious
then we got splendiferous
two dollars super chat phil walk around
with saxado ready to
drop it could be called david's
unchained
[Laughter]
then we got flush jackson 20 different
chat peace love and helps the lords
jaffee and this great community thank
you as well oh flush was over there on
on um
shout out to your guys cross pollinating
i love you yeah that's fantastic that's
what's up man we're good we're caught up
all right so it's time for me to go
everybody did they look man i appreciate
everybody we know is the spicy one for
those that
we're a little offended by the language
you know saying we apologize but look we
yeah we knew that we knew we weren't
getting
he
like regardless how you guys feel uh you
know we don't agree with everything the
man says but he does come out there and
what you see is what you get right and
listen
i love the dude so listen at the end of
the day i gotta go no
oh there's still more soft there oh we
got another one okay hold on one second
we got mandingo mcfickins ten dollar
super chat sucks about uh sf though uh
let it fully cook i should get back
i think from a date setting expectation
companies need to under commit and over
deliver on release dates yes another
great show and i'll just say thank
everybody for pulling up again we're
going to have guests on that's going to
have different opinions we
actually got to give the chat credit for
the most part yeah super respectful and
no one really said no one went out of
pocket what i'm saying i think people
are realizing that like just because we
have guests on that uh you know
what's more uh controversy
like doesn't mean that you know
we don't share their their their outputs
we just want to give them a a platform
to respectfully say what they meant
and you know
and that that's how we that's how we've
always been from the calling uh you know
everything yeah we've had a couple
guests on that people just do not like
and when we see you two when we see your
tweets we see your your chat in the
comments it's like i'm not watching this
the best thing is we understand that if
you don't like a certain guest we'll see
you next week but i give him credit like
for the most part people people did show
up still you know i mean and there
wasn't the negative the super negative
vitriol like we used to get it passed so
to me i want to give the realm credit
you know what i'm saying for at least
coming in listen and if they still
disagree we understand and for those who
got some extra context great you know
that's it but look fantastic show we got
to get up out of here
again sunday is going to be lit we will
see y'all anything else we got
everything cool the business is taken
care of
do you want to announce next week's show
or are you already putting it out there
well i mean we might as well they know
they're coming there's only a certain
amount of time we can do it sorry let's
go next
most likely so i won't give you guys a
hundred percent
but we will be having our playstation
2022 predictions next week yes uh we
don't
oh we we have a panel for the most part
we're not gonna say that
uh but we we uh
i will we'll announce it maybe what
friday-ish of who the panel is going to
be because i got to do a bunch of video
i didn't know so stay tuned we got that
we also got other guests coming let's go
we got a lot of stuff lined up for y'all
salute to the realm enjoy your sunday we
out peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so